Oh,
you creeps that are controlling money
all throughout the world.
Your time is slowly closing in.
Am I right?
Yup.
Andrea is Antonopoulos author a
published author of the Internet of
money.
Uh,
you've been on the show many times
before,
but you've never been on the show two
days after a book,
fresh off the presses.
Tell a story about how this book got
delivered to you today because it's kind
of hilarious.
Yeah.
So nobody knew about this.
This is my announcement.
This is my second book.
First book was mastering Bitcoin was for
techies.
Uh,
the internet of money is for everybody
else and it's a collection of my talks.
And I was having the first copy
delivered to my hotel this morning in
order to bring it to the show and give
it to you.
And,
uh,
it,
it was a day late.
It was supposed to be delivered
yesterday and I'm waiting and I'm,
I'm refreshing the tracking number site.
And then you said,
do you know we can push it back by half
hour because you're running a bit late.
And,
and in that half hour,
the book got delivered.
It literally was printed September 5th
this is the first copy I've touched and
it's yours.
Oh boy.
I've got it folks.
Okay,
issue zero zero zero one now why did
they do that?
Not just one.
Why don't they just make it one?
Why does everybody have to do a one?
Well,
I'm not printing 10,000 issues so,
well,
they never go.
It's never like zero,
zero,
zero zero one did they ever do that pair
of shoes once recently with that?
It was like one,
not a Twi.
You in one of my ears only.
What the hell is going on there?
Fucked up on.
I can't have you in my left ear.
It's like you're like the voice of God
or the voice of bad.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I got it too.
So please stick around.
Yeah,
that's too weird.
We can't have that.
Try it again.
Check,
check.
Nope,
you fucking Weirdo.
You're coming in my left ear.
Only probably the rest of America too,
right?
Yeah.
They can't have that.
People are at the gym gone and I'll tell
him,
fuck Jamie's in my left ear.
So this is a collection of all your
talks.
What has changed in the world of bitcoin
since the last time we spoke?
We spoke and we hung out in Vegas,
which was great.
I had a great time with you.
And um,
but what,
what has changed in the world of bitcoin
since the last time?
Well,
it's been about a year and a half almost
and so much so much happening in the
meantime.
But we had a pretty slow 2015 and 2016
pick top again.
Um,
2015 still coming off a slow and gradual
drop in the price.
People were very reluctant and
skeptical.
The media was constantly bashing
bitcoin.
And then,
um,
at the same time we saw this really
interesting phenomenon where the banks
started getting interested in this
thing,
but
not bitcoin itself.
No,
the blockchain,
the technology behind Bitcoin,
which is rather amusing.
I,
I look at that a bit as if,
you know,
the Horse Buggy Association of America
is going,
oh,
we like this automobile thing you've
designed,
but we have a very big investment in Hay
and horses and stables and veterinarian.
So,
um,
we're gonna use the technology behind
the automobile,
the pneumatic tire,
and we're going to revolutionize horse
buggies.
But in all fairness,
I think what you're saying,
it's hilarious,
but in all fairness,
it is a weird thing to invest in,
like to go all in on bitcoin.
I mean,
I know you do it,
but you also make all of your money this
way.
And this is,
you know,
you're,
you're a proselytizing person when it
comes to Bitcoin,
right?
Um,
for good reason.
But for the average person saves,
saved up actual cash money their whole
life and is involved in this established
system of money to throw all their money
into Bitcoin,
that would be insane.
You watched the money fluctuate,
it goes up and it goes down when I'm
thinking,
I'm glad you said that,
that it would be insane.
No,
that's,
that would be a terrible idea.
Right?
But don't you think that that's probably
why the media bashes it and why banks
are just looking at it going like people
see that there's a growing number of
people that are using it for
transactions.
There's Bitcoin ATM is now and people
are using it to,
to purchase things.
There's several companies that accept
bitcoin for products for actual real
physical products.
But yeah,
but I mean it's not an investment and it
shouldn't be treated as an investment.
Um,
I mean I don't even mean like as an
investment.
I mean as like a primary source of money
of,
of if you decided to take all of your
money,
not as an investment,
but just say,
I'm going,
going to live off a bit coin,
I'm going to spend bitcoin.
Like your money is going to go up and
down.
Yeah.
That's going to be really hard.
Especially if you're,
um,
if you're accustomed to privileged
banking,
like if you have the kind of banking
that we have in this country,
if you actually have access to that and
you have a,
a nice visa debit card and you don't
pain account fees and your money doesn't
get confiscated by a dictator too often
and you know,
you can earn your money and interact
with other people,
then why,
why would you use bitcoin?
The simple answer is that's not really
the use case,
but there are lots of people around the
world who simply don't have access to
that.
And for them,
you know,
in many cases,
big coin is the stable currency.
You know,
Asca,
an Argentinian,
Venezuelan,
a Brazilian,
uh,
Supriya to Greek and the list goes on
and on and on.
Uh,
whether they're worried about volatility
in bitcoin and in many cases if they've
heard of it,
if they've used it,
that's the stable currency.
Their national currency is far,
far worse.
Right.
Did you say Brazil?
Yeah,
Brazil has had to massive devaluation
the last year.
How much devaluation?
Cause I know that they have experienced
some sort of a really radical economic
downturn,
which is really interesting because a
few years ago when we first started
going into Brazil,
their economy was booming,
right?
W We,
I'm saying the UFC,
yeah.
They're in a currency crisis right now.
Massive currency crisis that's going on.
Well,
a apart from the political crisis that's
going on,
and I won't speak for that because I'm
not a Brazilian,
but you know,
they've had impeachment proceedings.
They just impeached their president.
Um,
there's been a lot of economic
difficulty with the country and I think
they,
their currency has devalued almost 30%
in the last year of 20 or 30%.
Some staggering amount.
Currencies don't move like that.
Mainstream national currencies that have
very large economies behind them simply
don't move like that.
We've seen it happen on the,
a couple of times we've seen it happen
in,
in Greece,
in Cyprus,
during the economic crisis.
We saw it happen in Britain,
uh,
during brexit.
And if we've seen it in places like
Brazil,
Venezuela,
Argentina,
and places like that,
how much currency did,
how much of a percentage of Britain you
lose during brexit?
Almost 20% in a day.
Wow.
And three things responded to that's in
the opposite direction.
Gold,
the Japanese yen and bitcoin heading in
the exact opposite direction,
a bit coin climb,
20% that they almost really,
so did Britain rebound.
Um,
it did a bit,
but it's still in historic close.
I'm multi decade lows.
So they took a really big hit.
And what we've seen again and again is
at times of crisis,
um,
we see this pattern repeating where
people use bitcoin as a safe haven
investment to get money out of a
national currencies,
especially where there are very strict
currency capital controls.
So one of the reasons we've seen a big
coin,
probably one of the reasons we've seen a
lot of activity with bitcoin in China is
because of currency controls.
Every time the yuan,
the Chinese currency devalues against
the dollar and it's done.
So I think four times in the last here,
every time there's a massive uptick in
bitcoin buying in China.
So people are parking the money in
bitcoin or using it to convert it to
other currencies and get money out of
the country.
So what is the biggest fluctuation that
bitcoin is had?
Um,
well it depends whether you look at it
on a monetary basis or on a percentage
basis.
If you look at the movements now,
it can go up 30 40 even a hundred bucks
in a day.
Um,
which seems like a lot,
but as a percentage,
the biggest fluctuations that had were
in 2010 and 2011 when it rose from under
a dollar or two over $30 and then back
down to under a dollar in a period of a
couple of months.
For people who don't understand what
this means when you're saying it,
a hundred bucks or a dollar $30 like
what?
What does that in relationship to one
bitcoin one bitcoin equals $30 in 2011.
And what does it equal right now?
617 $617 Jesus,
it was about $230 at the beginning of
this gear.
So it's seen a massive ramp pop and a
renewal of interest that,
okay,
so massive ramp up,
but like what's the fluctuation?
So if it's at 616 is that what you said?
Yup.
It's tripled since the beginning of the
year almost.
Is it possible that it could drop to
like 200 tomorrow?
Yes.
See that scares the shit out of people.
And,
and which is why you know at,
but here's,
here's the,
here's the truth.
Over the seven years that it's existed,
the fall utility as a percentage has
been going down every single here.
So as the economy gets bigger,
the bigger it is,
the more stable it is.
Eight doesn't get buffeted around,
right.
It's just like a very large boats
doesn't get pushed around by the waves.
And bitcoin is like a Zodiac next to the
U S dollars titanic.
And the Little Zodiac is bouncing up and
down on the waves a lot terrain.
And it might be uncomfortable at times.
Of course,
if you're heading to an iceberg,
you want to be in the thing that can
actually turn on a dime.
That's a good way to look at it.
But,
uh,
I don't know if it's a fair analogy,
but it's a good way of looking at it.
It's fall a and,
and that's part of,
it's part of the fact that a 10 to $12
billion economy stretched across the
entire globe is a small economy as a
currency.
Now in the interest of making this a
standalone podcast.
So people are not going to go back and
listen to all the other podcasts that
we've done.
Explain very briefly if you could,
what is bitcoin and how does it work?
I'm glad I have this opportunity to do
it again because every time we have a
new audience,
so bitcoin is Internet money.
It's a system of money that exists on
the Internet,
was created on the Internet,
and it allows you to send and receive
value the the same way you can send and
receive an email anywhere in the world
instantaneously without intermediaries.
Um,
and that's kind of what you see at first
glance behind that.
It's a whole platform.
It is.
As the title of the book says,
the Internet of money.
It is,
it is a set of protocols that allow you
to basically exchange value with other
people.
But you can do a lot more with it than
just that.
Most people will use it as a currency.
It's basically money that you can
transmit from your smartphone to
somebody else's smartphone directly,
just like cash.
Um,
but electronic,
and the thing about it that's unique is
that it's not owned by any corporation,
any bank or any government.
Just like the web isn't told by anyone
or email isn't told by anyone.
And there's lots of companies that can
send and receive email.
There's lots of companies that can set
up websites.
There's a lot of companies that can set
up applications that use bitcoin.
And I should say that when you set it up
for me,
the first time he did it,
a bunch of people donated bitcoin.
So what I did was I'd said whatever
people donated,
I would match.
I would double it.
And then we would donate it to fight for
the forgotten.
They've build wells in the Congo and we
built,
I don't remember how many Justin Wren
said,
but it was a,
I don't even remember how much money,
but it was many thousands of dollars
people donated and then I doubled it and
then we sent it over to the Congo.
So the bitcoin community is very
generous,
is my point that that is true and part
of that generosity comes from the fact
that a lot of the people in this
community are very excited about this
technology and want to share it without
this.
They want to tell other people about
this technology.
It's really quite interesting what
happens when you create a form of money
that is truly global and we really don't
have forms of money that a truly global,
if you,
even even with your very advanced
banking system and your access to all of
the technology that you have in the
American banking system,
if you try to send money to some
countries,
it's almost impossible to do.
And I experienced this every time I get
paid in Bitcoin,
I'll go into a conference in Europe,
um,
and I'll do one conference with the
banking industry and one conference with
the bitcoin community and the little
bitcoin conference.
It's going to be free to attend.
And I,
I don't make any money,
but they sometimes cover some of my
expenses and I'll send an invoice and
the banking industry conference will
send me a wire transfer.
It takes on average four weeks for me to
get it with several calls to find out
where it went,
what's going on,
why did it get lost?
And it takes me on average 15 minutes to
get paid in bit coin,
no matter which country and being paid
is he,
this is the cynic in me is this because
when they take the money and they're
transferring it and they're moving it
around and now it's sitting in banks.
When banks have money,
if they have your money,
even if it's just for a few weeks,
they have the opportunity to use that
money to make more money.
Are they doing that?
Um,
it,
it certainly doesn't,
uh,
it doesn't hurt to keep it a bit longer.
They're doing it primarily because,
uh,
because the system has a series of
intermediaries and each of those
intermediaries represent a risk.
If one of those intermediary says,
I have the money for Mr Antonopoulos
wire and you give that money to
Antonopoulos,
but the intermediary doesn't give it to
you,
you're out of money.
Right?
So there's those risks with every
intermediate you put in,
there's risk.
And that's called counterparty risk.
The,
because of the way the banking system is
with perhaps five,
six,
seven intermediaries in a single
transfer,
that creates a lot of cumulative risk.
And they protect without risk,
by slowing things down.
And that risk doesn't exist in bitcoin
because it's from one party directly to
another.
No counter parties.
That's one of the core principles.
The funny thing,
I had this conversation with my bank and
said I had done this um,
conference in Germany,
Frankfurt at the headquarters of the
Bundesbank.
Now for those of your viewers or
listeners who don't know,
the Bundesbank is the Federal Bank of
Germany and they probably consider the
United States Federal Reserve to be a
mediocre creditor compared to the
Bundesbank.
This is like the best credit rating on
the planet,
right?
And I'm going to speak at a conference
there and they're paying me for my
expenses and they send a wire transfer
and I call my bank and after four weeks
they finally find it and tell me,
we've received your bank,
your bank wire transfer.
We're going to hold it
because of the risk profile.
I don't understand.
Well you haven't been paid by this
particular payer before,
so we're going to put a hold on.
It said,
you do know this is the Bundesbank
you are holding.
And they held it for two weeks.
You are holding for two weeks because of
the credit risk of the Federal Bank of
Germany,
the most credit worthy institution.
I'm not trying to receive money from
Somalia,
you know,
this isn't even something weird.
And if,
if even they campaign me in the age of
the Internet instantaneously,
there is something wrong with this
banking system.
And there is because I got paid for the
bitcoin conference who was doing in the
same town instantaneously.
But there's also concern on their,
their end about fraud,
right?
I mean isn't it,
but there's fraud with bitcoin as well.
I mean,
wasn't there,
um,
that issue with a,
those guys that were investigating the
dark web,
it turned out that the agents were
stealing bitcoin to the tune of hundreds
of thousands of dollars.
Wasn't that the case with,
um,
yes,
absolutely.
So the,
the difference,
the difference is a difference between
systemic fraud,
an individual case of fraud.
Um,
so,
um,
in Bitcoin as in the traditional banking
system,
if,
if a bank or an organization
concentrates a lot of money,
then you can go in and steal it.
You basically robbed the Bitcoin Bank,
just like people rob the normal bank.
And how would they do that?
Just hack into it.
So they hack in and they do it.
And this has happened many,
many times and this is a problem with
bitcoin banks as opposed to person to
person exchanges.
Correct.
Because the whole point of pick coin is
that you don't need to put your money in
the custody of someone else.
And if instead you use bitcoin as it is
intended,
where everybody keeps control of their
own money,
then in order to hack all of those
people either have to hack the bitcoin
protocol itself has not happened in
seven years.
And the way it's structured is
impossible.
Do or you
have to hack each individual account
holder and you can hack individual
account holders depending on their level
of security and sophistication.
But um,
you know,
to get very large amounts you have to
wait for them to give their money to
someone else.
What was that exchange?
The bitcoin bank that started off as
like a fantasy website and some,
what was that again?
Uh,
this was a Mt.
Gox in Japan,
the magic,
the gathering online,
which they see in the early days of
Bitcoin,
there were no exchanges.
So you've got to think back like,
do you remember on the web,
uh,
in the early days when even the,
the,
the largest,
most sophisticated corporations had a
page with a single logon,
a gray background,
and some flashing lights that said under
construction,
like in 1994,
that's where we are in bitcoin's still.
So there's,
there were no,
um,
well-run exchanges at the time.
It was very difficult to buy and sell
bitcoin.
And so this guy in Japan had a site that
could trade these magic,
the gathering online cards,
and he converted the sites to trade
currencies instead to create trade.
Cryptocurrencies.
Turns out it's a lot easier to hack in
and steal cryptocurrencies than it is to
steal the cards.
Whatever happened with that,
because the story was like hundreds of
thousands of dollars in bitcoins,
just hundreds of millions of dollars,
millions.
They didn't vanish that inventors,
someone stole it.
They got stolen,
they got cycled through the economy and
they're back in the economy now.
But just not with the same owners.
No one knows who.
That seems bizarre.
Like if you rob a bank,
like they can put a trace on the bills
and they can figure it out eventually.
And most people get caught.
Right?
Yeah.
Not really.
I mean,
no,
they if you,
if you do wire fraud perhaps,
but in many cases with cash,
bitcoin is like cash.
Uh,
it is equally untraceable it's very
difficult to actually catch like I think
recently,
um,
I was reading about the FBI closing the
DB cooper case.
It's the Guy who robbed the bank,
got into seven,
one seven aircraft,
opened the rear state case and jumped
out to the parachute over the midwest
and was never seen again.
Um,
I think that guy died though.
Hmm.
Well that,
that that would be a convenient,
a explanation for the failure of the FBI
to catch him.
Yeah.
It would be convenient,
but also didn't he like drop into the
woods?
I,
I don't know the details.
They never found him body or money ever
again.
But that can happen pretty easy.
I would be more likely or more,
uh,
apt to believe that if someone dropped
in the woods,
out of parachute with some fucking
haphazard gear and leapt out of the back
of a plane,
they probably died.
Probably got eaten by bears or
something.
Yes.
Or,
or found by a,
a local woods.
Men in the cabin who's like some,
some dude fell out of the sky with a
Satchel full of money.
Some my money.
I need a new chainsaw.
Yeah,
yeah.
Um,
but when you're stealing money from a
bank,
can't they trace the serial numbers?
Like if you steal cash,
like if you,
you go,
you know,
this is a robbery,
stick them up and you pointed a gun at
the teller and they fill up the bag with
currency and you run out the door.
Don't they have like a trace on that
money?
Like where they can,
if you spend the really ash,
no,
not really.
And they can't because they have all
kinds of,
I mean,
yes,
if they had a batch of sequentially
numbered clean money,
but that's not how most banks work.
What the money they have on hand is this
stuff that came,
deposited it in the last week,
um,
by various people,
cash businesses like Delis and grocery
stores and things like that.
And they have no idea what the numbers
on those bills are and they don't trace
it.
It's simply considered part of the risk
of business.
And what does this avoid?
Cooper's money before.
Oh Shit.
Some of it get this out of the left side
of my ear.
It's a bad cable after Resa.
Okay.
No sign of DB.
Cooper ever emerge.
Investigators doubt he survived and
never been able to determine his true
identity.
But a boy digging on the Columbia River
beach in 1980 found three bundles of
weathered $20 bills.
Cooper's cash.
According to the serial numbers,
that guy's dead as fuck.
They found his money.
Some of his money.
What did he like?
Left song of cause being sneaky.
I'm going to pretend I'm dead.
I'm just leave some of this here.
No,
they don't.
They only found like a very small,
I don't think they recovered more than a
tiny fraction of it.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
But I don't know.
I mean,
I don't remember the details when she's
dealing with 200 grand though.
I think it was only like $200,000 in
those days.
You could pay the national debt with
that kind of money.
What year was it?
Like sixties 71 there's a lot of money
in those days.
That db cooper stores and interesting
story.
It's a,
people love a story like that where
people don't get caught.
Yeah.
The mystery of the unknown.
All the Mt.
Gox thing.
The exchange is kind of a mystery to,
it's $100 million or many hundreds of
millions of dollar mystery inside story
of Mt.
Gox bitcoins,
$460 million disaster for 60 look at
that guy.
They're leading them around.
That's marlene embark palace.
Who's a,
yes.
That's the guy who is now out on parole,
I believe,
or on or pending trial.
So that guy's out $460 million and he's
out.
Yeah,
of course.
Well,
is he responsible?
Just cause he's retarded.
You know that.
That's one of the things we,
we don't know.
And maybe we'll never know how much of
that response,
whether it was deliberate,
whether it was an inside job,
whether it was a complaint,
competence.
Well,
he was certainly,
that was enormous,
of incompetent.
Enormous.
That's clear.
And when you listen to him talk,
I've heard him in speeches when he's
discussing the issue,
you're like,
wait a minute,
that guy,
uh,
yes,
exactly.
It's one of the,
have you heard Bernie madoff talk?
Yes.
True.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean,
the thing is the,
even,
even the most,
and the interesting thing is that just
up to the day before Bernie madoff was
indicted,
he was the top trusted name on Wall
Street.
He had the most stellar credit rating.
He was the head of the credit rating
agency for,
uh,
those types of funds that he was rated
under.
Um,
and the next day he's a CROC.
So
you can see these things happen
throughout human history.
Changing the form of money used doesn't
change that.
But if he changed the architecture of
money and you make it less necessary,
uh,
and um,
less useful to concentrate the money in
the hands of third parties that has an
impact.
And so that
one of the issues with this something
like Mt Gox or with any banking system
yes.
Other than the bitcoin system with,
I mean,
the problem is the counterparty risk if
you give your money to other people.
The entire reason we have oversight in
banking is because of the simple truth
that if you give your money to other
people,
eventually they'll try to steal it.
Uh,
that's it.
And the only reason they,
they don't cause someone in the bank is
going to have a tremendous need.
The tremendous gambling problem,
uh,
an addiction,
um,
something,
right?
Or just have a lack of empathy and
social socialization and just be,
you know,
correct.
Crooked.
But they don't even have to be crooked.
They can make a mistake and trading and
tried to cover it up with customer
money.
They can have a debt there.
Their parents may require an expensive
surgery that they can't afford.
There's lots of reasons why people
commit financial fraud and not all of it
is because they're just greedy,
evil assholes,
but,
right.
But the bottom line is that all of the
oversight system we have in banking,
which by the way fails again and again
and again and again to protect and
regular people from these thefts.
All of these systems we have exists for
that one reason.
So the answer is not build better
systems to watch the people who hold
your money is,
the answer is that bitcoin gives us,
don't let others hold your money,
hold your own money and then you don't
have this problem.
There was
recent investigative report about,
um,
a firm in Georgia,
I want to say it's Atlanta that has a
ridiculously high rate of success with
investments.
And they interviewed the Guy who runs it
and you know his reasons for why they're
so wildly successful and they make so
much more money than anybody else.
We're very suspect.
And they're closing in on this guy,
like what's going on over here?
And they think that not only is the
Bernie model,
not just Bernie Madoff,
but they,
they think that it's common and that
there's a lot of people that that might
be supplementing legitimate investments
with a pyramid scheme and that it's been
a standard operational model for a lot
of these firms because they've been able
to pull it off.
What we've seen again and again
throughout history in the area of
finance,
is that when there's a recession,
when there is a drop in income and
profitability for everyone,
uh,
that event is actually really good for
capitalism.
What it does is it washes out the
frauds.
It's washes out the failures,
it washes out the unprofitable
businesses.
It's a great cleansing event,
right?
Because the tide recedes and suddenly
you see who's not wearing swimming
trunks.
So
we knew there was something fishy going
on under the water,
but,
um,
that's a good way of looking at it.
When that happens in,
in Wall Street's all of those companies
that were simply reinvesting the,
the recent gains to pay the people who
are withdrawing their money or the
retirees that are supporting in their
pension fund,
et Cetera,
suddenly they don't,
they can't do that to any more.
They're washed out of the business.
A badly performing businesses
unprofitable.
As all of these things get washed out.
We haven't been doing this in this
country for the last three decades.
Instead,
what happens is every time there's a
recession,
the Fed steps in a or the government
steps in and basically they pump water
to raise the tide again,
right?
As much as possible.
And that means that a lot of the crux
float from recession to recession
without getting revealed worse,
it encourages that kind of behavior.
And so you get all of these businesses
whose only ability to make profits is
when the interest rates to zero and
there's $20 billion a month being
injected by the Fed and their business
model is take that and lend it to
consumers for 29 99 Apr.
Right?
Or do payday loans or sub prime loans or
sub prime auto student loans,
mortgages,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
You need a cleansing events to wash out
the fraud.
Um,
I like the example of a forest fire.
If you suppress all of the small fires
will happens,
is eventually you build up a lot of
undergrowth in the forest.
A small fire doesn't kill the trees.
It just cleans out the undergrowth.
You keep putting out the fires,
which we've seen since the 70s here in
the states.
You let all of the undergrowth grow up.
Then when a fire comes through,
it's not just a little forest fire,
it's a raging inferno now.
You can't put it out and it burns the
trees and destroys the soil.
Sterilizes the top foot of soil.
We've seen this happen,
right?
And so this is now happening in terms of
our economy,
which is that all of this,
um,
bubble creation doesn't get washed out
in a recession.
More stimulus,
more funding.
The Federal Reserve pumps more money
into the economy.
Trillions of dollars since 2008 and all
of this stimulus,
where does it go?
It goes into inflating not one bubble.
We had real estates,
but now we have real estates and
subprime auto and student loans and,
and,
and bonds and stocks and currencies all
inflating at the same time.
The,
is it possible to do a controlled burn
for the economy?
That's what they're doing.
And some places where they want to,
uh,
deal with the issue that,
you know,
you're talking about how there's stop
forest fires.
That's theoretically part of the mandate
of the Federal Reserve,
which most people don't realize is a
private corporation owned by the banks
and not a government agency.
Yeah,
that's a tricky name.
Yes.
Federal Reserve has nothing to do with
that.
Yeah.
It's kind of gross.
In fact,
I can't name say my publishing company
for the book,
the,
the federal publisher,
um,
they won't allow me to put the word
federal in the name of my company as
they shouldn't.
Right.
But in order to create an organization
like that,
you need an act of Congress.
Uh,
in fact,
actually what you need is an act of
Congress passed in the middle of the
night on a recess,
which is exactly how they pass the
Federal Reserve Act in 1913.
It has a long ass time ago.
Yup.
It's so ridiculous.
They keep that name.
But there is federal ammunition.
I should just say that you could buy
bullets company called federal
ammunition,
has nothing to do with the federal
government interest is to good good
company to buy bullets from.
[inaudible].
It just seems like the,
the controlled burn idea,
how would you apply that to the economy?
I mean,
if what we're talking about raise the
interest rates,
you raised them.
Yup.
It was,
drains the waste.
Drains the swamp,
raise the interest rates.
Basically the infrastructure controls
the cost of money.
If you make money more expensive than
those who borrowed have to have a pretty
good rate of investment in return on
their investment to invest that.
Right.
Otherwise they don't borrow money.
And it's an extremely unpopular idea
though.
Right?
So how do you get that across?
Well,
it's an,
it's an unpopular idea because,
um,
it benefits savers instead of debtors,
right?
So if you,
if you have savings,
it's a great idea.
I remember a time when I could get a
certificate of deposit for my savings in
the bank and I could get 3% here,
3%,
uh,
here,
right?
I can't get 0.3% now.
So savers get wiped out.
If you're a retiree who's got all of
their money in savings right now,
the return you're getting on those
savings isn't enough to cover your cost
of living.
So your money basically is shrinking.
And that's a tax on savers that,
um,
benefits debtors,
especially for a large debtors like the
federal government.
Yeah.
It's such a complicated system that for
the average person that's working all
day and you know,
you get home,
you have hobbies and family and things
that you want to do,
it's very difficult to get a grip on
exactly how money works.
Yes,
it is.
And it's one of them.
Thanks.
I found through my experiences doing
these talks that I do.
Um,
and I talk about that in the book too,
that the whole point of this particular
book,
the Internet of money is why bitcoin and
I talk about the philosophy behind
money,
the,
the topics of money that most people
don't understand.
And what's really astonishing is that
here I am and I'm,
I'm talking about is the greatest
experiment in money.
Um,
started in 2008,
2009 and this great experiment is
completely unprecedented in the history
of money.
And I'm not talking about Bitcoin,
I'm talking about 22 central banks,
similar caneously taking their interest
rate to zero and pumpings the largest
amount of money ever created into the
world economy trying to stop it from
collapsing.
And that has created the largest bubble
in history.
And the weird thing is that most people
are not even aware that they're living
in a time what we are doing this
completely unprecedented,
untested,
no one knows where it goes.
Huge monetary experiments in which 2
billion people are hostage as part of
it,
at least.
Right?
And nobody knows where this is going to
go.
But most economists,
mainstream economists say this doesn't
tend well
said mean though.
And then we have the other level of
monetary experiment,
which is,
Hey,
uh,
money on the Internet with a controlled
issuance.
Only a certain amount of the money is
created.
It's controlled by a mathematical
formula.
You can't make more.
And as a result,
it's got a stable
ply.
It sound money and it cannot be
manipulated by governments or banks.
Well,
it's so confusing for anyone as it is
when you get into the issue of what is
money and where's money coming from and
how does the Federal Reserve,
how does the government,
how does anybody create more money?
How do you print more money?
And if you are printing more money,
where's it coming from?
And what is it debt.
Right?
But what is it like,
what is,
he used to be gold and it used to be the
gold standard.
It used to be if you had a dollar as a
dollar's worth of gold,
it was a note that was worth a dollar's
worth of gold.
Yes,
that made sense.
And that stopped what
first stopped in 1936,
I believe,
Bretton Woods agreement.
And then it stopped completely in 1971
when Nixon closed the gold window,
he basically said,
if anyone comes to your bank and gives
you one silver dollar or one gold dollar
and says,
I want my silver,
you say no.
Um,
and basically defaulted on the backing
of US dollars,
buy gold.
I met this wacky guy
a long time ago that was,
um,
he was coming on the comedy store's this
really odd guy for a bunch of reasons,
but one of the things is he carried a
gun everywhere he went and he believed
in,
he believed in precious gold coins that
were minted outside of the federal
government and using those as currency.
Yes.
And so he would have these coins that he
carried with him,
everything.
And he would try to pay for things in
these,
Colin's like gold and silver coins,
mostly silver.
It's silver coins.
And he was trying to explain to me that
this is legal and that,
you know,
they're supposed to accept these.
And it was a very weird stuff.
It was a very,
very odd,
he was very annoying too,
as well as guys.
They like talk to you.
He kept touching you,
would talk to you and hold you and like,
like grab your arm and hold you and
touch you and all right fucker.
What a year here.
A control freak.
And he said it's like a weird control
freak.
You know,
if someone's saying something to you and
they are holding onto you whether saying
that to you,
unless you're in love with them,
you know like you creates a very strange
moment.
Yeah.
Why are you holding me?
Can I get loose here?
What if I have to run away real quick so
have to break this grip.
But this guy used to carry these coins
around with them.
I can't fucking sack.
He likes to touch his money.
Elvis off commercials and shit like
that.
No Man,
they were like some weird fucking coin
with like an American Eagle on them and
yeah,
they're not weird.
They're minted in the u s full silver
coins right now.
They're weird.
Weirdest fuck.
They're weird if you tried to use them
to buy a coffee.
Although a lot of people buy these and
gold coins and small gold bars as
investments,
they keep him in a safe,
right?
And the idea is if there is a
significant crash in the car and seat,
then these have holding value,
right?
Um,
and it's not,
it's I think,
perfectly sane to say,
if you have some money put aside in
savings,
don't put it all in stocks.
Maybe diversify,
put a bit in precious metals,
maybe put a bit in digital currencies,
maybe put a bit in commodities and other
things.
Um,
that's kind of reasonable and fasting.
And here's the thing.
A lot of the people who have these kinds
of attitudes come from families and from
cultures where there has been a time in
the past two generations where you leave
in the middle of the night with all of
your belongings in a pillowcase and with
people with guns and dogs after you
trying to murder you.
And this happens today in Syria,
right?
Um,
it happens,
uh,
one generation to go to my parents'
generation in,
in Greece with the Nazis.
Um,
Eh,
it happens to the Russian people.
It happens to people all over the world.
And when that happens,
and it's,
it's really cool.
So when it happens generation before,
right?
Your parents tell you the stories,
it's a,
it's a different feeling.
It hasn't happened to most Americans,
uh,
in at least two or three generations.
But when that happens,
what do you put in the pillowcase?
And I'll tell you something,
the pieces of paper are worthless when
that happens.
And that's why some people do want to
have physical coin.
Now,
one of the things we've noticed now is
that digital currencies may start to
serve a role.
The fact is that you can memorize 12
English words and carry your entire
bitcoin wallets in your head.
And if you do that well,
you 12 English words,
what are those words?
Level celsion party on.
Yeah.
So,
um,
you can generate a bitcoin wallet,
right?
And then make a backup of it.
And for convenience,
some of the inventors in the space
developed a system where you can back up
any bitcoin wallet,
even if it has millions and billions of
transactions and assets in it,
you can back it up to between 12 and 24
English words that are generated
automatically by the program.
Be like that speech and pulp fiction
where Samuel Jackson pulls a gun on that
kid.
That could be your password.
Yes.
Um,
you don't pick the words though.
Oh,
you don't pick the words.
You're going to get a series so forwards
and they're going to be,
um,
you know,
asparagus forest,
uh,
attorney and would've whatever all I
liked dix please.
Shit on my head.
Yeah,
no sentences and snow where it's like
that.
But think about the power of being able
to transport an unlimited amount of
money simply by memorizing 12 words that
can't be confiscated from you when
you're a refugee.
Kate's amazing.
I mean,
you look the whole,
uh,
the whole idea behind it is incredibly
fascinating to me and I've been a fan of
it since the time I met you.
And before that I was reasonably
interested in it.
But of course,
having you a aluminate it in such a
great way really made it much more,
um,
much more enticing and much more
interesting.
And I've always been,
I'm curious from that point on as to
where it's gonna go.
And,
uh,
I just don't,
I don't know,
when I look at the landscape of money,
when I look at the landscape of,
uh,
people that are willing to make this
leap,
I don't know what it would take to get
people fully onboard with Bitcoin,
but I believe like you do that the
system that we have now,
the banking system is incredibly corrupt
and just bizarre
and fragile and frail.
And I think that's the thing that most
people are missing.
It looks giant imposing.
It's been there for a century that is
not a sign of strength.
You find that the company in Atlanta
that has this,
a massive,
a return on your investment that's being
investigated.
I'm not sure if I found the right guy
and I don't want to call them.
Okay,
look again,
but
it's gotta be a bunch of those people
out there that are doing that,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
There's,
there's a lot of,
um,
Eh,
a system like that which is,
which is very opaque,
which most people don't understand,
is the kind of system you want to
corrupt because that's where you can
make the most money without anybody
noticing.
And of course,
you know,
financial crime is not really prosecuted
in this country.
Um,
in 2008 giants crisis,
millions of homeowners kicked out of
their homes,
illegal foreclosures,
Robo signing mills,
blah,
blah.
The only person who went to jail,
Bernie Madoff,
who stole from the rich,
pretty much everybody else.
Scottfree it is pretty interesting.
It's almost like he was just a scape
goat.
Well,
he was obviously a crook.
He was obviously a car.
He was obviously a crook,
but in a sociopath or something,
surrounded by hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of quirks in the same scale and
giant investment banks that are just as
corrupt.
And we don't see that right.
You,
you can get,
you can get pulled over for a busted
tail lights and thrown in jail in plenty
of the states in this country for six
months for having an herb in your car.
And at the same time,
you can put a million people out of
their homes through straight up fraud
with mountains of evidence and emails
and things like that.
And they're untouchable.
That system,
the problem isn't the fact that there's
fraud.
The problem is that the,
the system itself is fragile because of
that.
And if it was just them going out of
business,
when the fragile system has problems,
when it has hiccups as it did in 2008,
that's fine.
But it's not just them going out of
business.
It's a generation of kids who leave
college with nothing waiting for them,
but a,
a job.
Um,
and you know,
coming into a generation where their
parents could get by with one income and
a household and now three jobs each in a
household of two.
And you can't afford to buy a car,
let alone a house.
Right?
So we're part of the new sharing
economy.
And what does the sharing economy,
it's the,
I can tone anything cause I can't afford
anything economy.
So that whole generation is now
suffering because of that fragility of
the system and the fragility hasn't gone
away,
but I don't want to dwell too much on
the negative.
Right.
Because the thing that I find positive
and interesting about bitcoin is that it
serves a global society.
It is truly global,
transnational money.
There's plenty of places in the world
that have it worse than the u s there's
some places that have it better
financially.
Um,
but it really is quite an incredible
concept to be able to have this money
that can operate on a global basis.
And with that,
the opportunities to a buy and sell and
trade and invest and borrow
internationally.
The fact that what we did with the
fundraising here to fundraise for those
wells,
right?
I,
we don't know if that was just people in
the u s donating.
It wasn't,
I can guarantee you there were people
from all over the world donating.
That's almost impossible to do with
traditional payment systems.
You could have then sent that money
directly to where the wells were being
built again anywhere in the world.
And that's really exciting to me.
People are uncomfortable with bitcoin
because it's represents changing one of
the fundamental ancient technologies of
civilization money.
And we've only changed that technology
four or five times in the history of
human civilization.
We've gone from bare bones,
barter systems.
Here's a goat,
give me three chickens,
right to systems of precious metals
and other nice objects,
feathers,
shells,
et Cetera,
to exclusively precious metals,
too.
Precious metal stamps with the faces of
kings.
And then at some point around the 15th
century,
you start seeing certificates of deposit
for,
for precious metal being exchanged.
Paper notes that I have a deposit of
gold there.
I'm not going to move the gold from my
deposit to your deposit.
They'll just give you the piece of paper
that says you're now the owner and paper
money is introduced and and then plastic
in the 1950s a diner's club,
traveler's checks and the first credit
cards.
And if you think any of these
transitions were smooth,
none of them were smooth.
You go to someone who's been using
precious metals for 10 generations and
you say,
hey,
this piece of paper is money.
They're like,
give me something shiny that I can bite.
That's money.
This paper,
I don't know who you are.
Go Away.
How long has that transition?
400 years.
Right?
Until broad acceptance of paper money,
400 years with huge resistance.
It took almost 40 years for credit cards
to go mainstream with bitcoin.
We're going to do it probably in less
than 20 you think so?
But in think cause almost 10.
It's seven.
Seven,
yeah.
And it's accelerating very much.
I think in some countries you're going
to see either bitcoin or cryptocurrency
very similar or based on bitcoin be used
as commonly as a national currency.
We're not looking to displace national
currencies.
We're looking to supplement them.
I think the idea of being that people
will get comfortable using multiple
currencies just like many places they
are.
If you're operating,
um,
you know,
between the border of Kenya and Tanzania
for example,
you're probably going to use four
different currencies,
Kenyan money,
Tanzania and US dollars in euros easily.
Possibly.
Also South African rand,
so you've got four or five currencies.
You can stop at a four year old in the
streets and ask them what the exchange
rate is and they'll tell you right?
Because they trade for their parents and
merchant stalls along the border and
they have people coming with all kinds
of different currencies.
It's not that difficult to assume that
there's digital currencies in that
future,
either there or in a major modern
metropolis where people are using
bitcoin to transact online,
to buy things,
virtual things,
music,
video,
things like that.
What you want to make very,
very small payments were credit cards
and not suitable and use bitcoin as well
as their normal currencies.
What is the progress that makes you so
optimistic?
Like what is the,
maybe if you could point to any one
thing or several things that make you
optimistic about Bitcoin's future?
Well,
I think watching it as,
as a computer scientist,
as a technologist,
I look at this and I see innovation that
is accelerating.
And I see much of the early vision
opening up the possibility of doing
things that are so far outside what we
could do with traditional money.
Um,
that it,
it often blows my mind.
Uh,
for example,
um,
uh,
technology that's being introduced into
bitcoin now is called payment channels.
Um,
and what it allows you to do is,
uh,
to do a very high volume of very small
transactions at a very rapid rate.
Let's say you're,
you want to watch a video and you want
to pay the owner of that video to send
it to you.
Um,
how about paying by the second?
And so you say you set up basically an
account and you pay by every second of
video,
maybe every fifth of a second,
200 milliseconds,
a video at a time,
and you're paying a fraction that is a
thousandth of a penny.
And You keep watching video and paying a
thousandth of a penny for every fifth of
a second on this drip metered basis.
Well,
you're not doing it.
You're a computer.
Software is doing it,
communicating with our computer software
and now you can do this really
incredible thing.
You can pay for content what it's
actually worth.
Um,
whereas the thresholds for payments on a
credit card is two to $3.
Unless you're apple and you're doing
billions,
in which case you can take it down to 99
cents.
That's about the lowest you can go.
So meaning watching something on youtube
or some similar videos,
streaming device,
you would have to pay service rather,
you'd have to pay,
but you would pay a very minuscule
amount.
Yes.
Like what are you talking about?
A couple of cents like to watch a,
no,
I'm,
I literally mean a thousandth of 500th
of a cent to watch a video.
Well,
it depends how long the video is,
right?
You could,
you could,
yeah,
it could be a scale.
You could be a penny.
Yeah.
You could be a penny or half a penny or
a 10th of a penny to watch a video.
But what,
how would that work for the people that
are providing content?
Like,
well,
you see,
the thing is they operate at a scale.
I have,
um,
30,000 views on one of my videos,
right?
So Youtube pays me 30 bucks for that.
If I put ads in front,
if I was getting a penny from each of my
customers,
or because these are like hour long
videos,
maybe I'm going to charge more baby,
I'm going to charge 25 cents,
you know,
30,000 views,
25 cents.
Somebody do the math please.
Uh,
I'm not good at selling himself,
Matt Graham.
No,
it's like 70 bucks.
$70.
25 cents is a quarter of a dollar.
No,
it's 7,000.
You're right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So it's a rare time where I'm writing a
math fucking quick question like that.
So maybe I'm going to charge less maybe.
But in any case,
I can beat what youtube gives me in
terms of ad revenue with each customer
paying a fraction
of a penny.
And here's the real question,
but I get this content for free right
now on trust.
Why would I pay a fraction of a penny?
You don't get it for free.
You're paying.
No,
you're paying him.
Yes.
And micro violations of your privacy.
What's your,
if the product costs less than two or $3
making the stank face.
Now,
if agree with you,
but that was a weird way to word it.
Yeah.
If it's at another cord,
if,
if the payment is worth less than two or
$3,
right.
Which means they can't collect it with a
credit card.
What they're doing is they're selling
your data to advertisers.
There are selling your identity,
your demographics,
your data to advertise a series here
you're getting,
you're having to give up things.
You don't give them up at that moment.
You've given them a previously when you
registered for the thing and verified
your email and then verified your age
and your gender and provided all of this
demographic information,
which they then parcel up and give to
the advertisers,
but you're still paying for the content.
What you're,
you're paying by the fact that you can
no longer engage with the web without it
being filtered to what they think you
want and who they think you are.
Right.
So you're getting this highly filtered,
pigeonholed view of content and they do
that using your information to present
what they think you would like to watch
based on what they've sold to the
advertisers.
You're no longer a customer,
you're the product.
The customer is the advertising agency.
Whereas if you sell content directly,
you reestablish the relationship of who
is the creator
and who is the customer,
the consumer of this content,
and you cut out the two middlemen.
Yeah,
you're cutting out advertising,
good luck.
And also the other thing is like people
don't want to pay,
even if it's a fraction of a penny,
they just don't want to pay.
I disagree.
Do you think of people,
there's a lot of dopes at watch youtube
all day.
Like they sit in front of their
computer,
they slack jaw from morning to night and
they just watch youtube videos.
If they just calculated those fractions
of a penny all day,
that would be dollars and dollars every
day,
which would mean the hundreds of dollars
every few months.
Well,
you've got to think about this as a
broader economy because a lot of these
people could also earn a bet by making
a,
a good comment,
uh,
which actually ends up covering some of
their costs of viewing so that you've
got to think about it.
You can earn from comments.
Yeah.
That's where it gets really interesting.
Blockchain,
all this that you're talking about.
No,
you could do this with bit coin.
You could do this with blockchain.
You,
what is the difference in blockchain and
Bitcoin?
Sorry to hijack that.
No,
no problem.
Um,
so blockchain is one of the technologies
used in bitcoin.
It's a distributed database where,
um,
all of the transactions are linked
together using cryptographic proofs.
Um,
bitcoin is one implementation of a
blockchain.
And blockchain has now been used as a
marketing term.
That means very little.
It's kind of like web two.
Dot.
Oh,
we don't really know what it is.
Right.
It's a lot of hurry datto yet.
Yeah.
Uh,
which is blockchain.
Oh,
okay.
That's ironic,
isn't it?
Hit?
It is.
Yeah.
And it's nebulous.
Um,
but the point is that you can do more
than just currency.
Um,
earlier we were talking a bit about
trolling on twitter and other platforms
like that before we started the live
broadcast.
Well,
think about what a troll is doing.
What they're doing is they're stealing
attention.
They're taking attention without
contributing anything back to the
community.
Uh,
there's an interesting and fairly,
um,
effective market solution to this,
which is instead of assigning someone to
do oversight and decide who is and who
isn't a troll and censor them,
you basically allow people to contribute
again,
a minuscule fraction for the comments
they like,
they [inaudible] power like thumbs up.
But with each one of those likes and
thumbs up,
you attach a 10000th of a penny with it,
you know,
irrelevant,
small,
tiny money.
Um,
and then the people who write comments
that are broadly appreciated,
that add value to the community or in a
tiny bit of money,
not really anything serious,
but if they tried to comment,
they have to spend a bit of that credit
that they've earned that reputation that
they've earned.
And if they're not a troll,
it doesn't,
it all comes out equal in the wash.
They don't end up spending anything.
They don't end up burning anything.
It's just participation in the
community.
But if they're a troll is suddenly
starts getting interesting because now
it gets expensive to steal the attention
to the community because the,
you have
positive feedback,
the more expensive it gets for you to po
post until eventually you're priced out.
But does that also,
that also can kind of enforce or,
or encourage confirmation bias because
if you go to a website that's just
completely ridiculous and it's a message
board filled with morons and you argue
with them,
it could cost you to argue with morons
cause you're going to downvote you.
Yeah.
It could.
Um,
and just choose to not comment,
but you could,
you've got to think about this again
across a broader economy with a broader
set of forums in which in some you are
valued experts and other,
you're the idiot who's arguing against
the conventional wisdom and,
and you know,
you can actually balance these things
out.
But if you go to a flat earth forum and
argue with those people and it costs you
money.
Yes.
I had an argument with someone about
chem trails.
How did that go?
It went really,
it went very,
very interestingly.
I wasn't expecting them to change their
mind.
Um,
and they really wanted to hear my
opinion and it was really interesting
because we started the conversation.
I said,
okay,
first I'm a pilot,
I have a pilot's license,
I fly small planes.
That puts you at an extreme advantage.
Yes.
This conversation.
Well you think you would think that
it's,
I mean,
and it's,
it's not,
it's not appeal to authority.
It's saying those nozzles that you're
pointing at,
I know what those are.
I have to,
I have to walk around the plane before I
take off and make sure all of them have
correctly attached in the place they
should be doing the things they should
be doing.
Otherwise I don't survive the flight.
So you are a part of the chem trail
sprayers,
association of America,
you're saying?
Yes.
That was pretty much the conclusion we
reached.
What are those nozzles?
I'm actually in the,
in the,
the ones pointing forward are called
peto tubes and they're used to measure
the velocity of the aircraft through the
air by a pressure differential.
And the ones pointing backwards are
usually to break up of fortresses.
These are little swirly currents of
arrows that come off the wing,
the cause turbulence and you want to
break those up so they don't swirl.
Um,
by the weight of the trails are clouds.
How long have you been a shell with a
water vapors government?
Indeed,
of course.
I'm Michelle.
I'm Michelle for,
can't believe one of the things I'm
interested in.
Shut it off Jamie.
Yeah,
I've had these conversations with so
frustrating.
You can present mountains of evidence if
someone really,
really doesn't want to believe they,
they really will not believe.
There's also,
um,
I mean it's been going on forever.
I mean if you go back to the 1940s,
there's pictures,
black and white photos from world war
one or World War II rather,
where you can see planes leaving behind
these enormous controls.
So it's a argument.
I mean,
it really is.
I mean we've known for a long time that
depending upon how much moisture is in
the atmosphere,
when planes pass through it,
they will create clouds.
And it's just real simple changes the
temperature of the air and it creates
clouds and it's usually on hazy days.
Not only that,
but NASA has a website where you can go
to it and it will accurately predict.
Contrary.
I was looking through that.
That is,
those are from propeller engines in the
1940s and what's happening is the
propeller is compressing the air and
when it compresses the air of the change
in pressure changes the dewpoint and the
dewpoint is what determines whether the
air moisture condenses into a visible
vapor,
into droplets that are clouds.
And so by pushing a thing through the
air,
uh,
you're pressing on the air and when you
press on the air,
that causes condensation to form.
And that conversation follows you in a
circular cloud behind the plane.
And this happens at any plane propeller
plane.
I've done it in a,
in a four seater Cessna,
that's,
that's smaller than a,
than a Fiat sedan.
Right.
And on a,
on a,
on a wet day,
you can see little trails coming off the
tips of the wings.
And I pretty short and put any spray
nozzles they or flipped this way.
I didn't,
I saw this,
which it said chem trail them and I
didn't flip it.
I didn't,
you don't how much liquid you would have
to have in your plane in order to spray
these enormous jets across the sky.
I mean,
it would be insane.
It would be insane.
I mean,
if the entire plane was filled up,
I mean filled and you would have so much
liquid that it would be visible from the
ground floating in space.
And then he talked to people,
you know,
I did that television show on Scifi,
I called Joe Rogan questions,
everything.
And one of the things that I questioned
was chem trail.
So I talked to a bunch of chem trail,
air quote experts.
And one of these guys had this study
that he had done on water.
And this standing water study was
proving that the spraying in the air was
making aluminum.
Uh,
it was putting aluminum in the water.
And the water supply.
And so he had this water tested.
And so I,
he showed me the test,
I'm going over the test.
I go,
well,
it's a sludge.
And he goes,
well,
it was water.
I gave them water.
I go,
okay,
but it says sludge,
like the laboratory that you sent this
stuff too,
says sludge.
And He,
and he was like,
well,
what is exactly sludge?
What's the definition?
I'm like,
well,
let's Google it.
So we googled sludge and what sludges is
water mixed with dirt?
So I said,
okay,
so your water mixed with dirt contains
aluminum.
Do you know how much aluminum there is
in dirt?
Because it's the exact amount that they
tested when they tested the world.
The water that you had with dirt.
So what happened is your dirt tested
positive for being dirt and you're using
that as proof that the government is
spraying the skies above everybody's
head.
And you want to talk about like a Piss
poor cost ineffective shitbag program
that does absolutely nothing.
Chem Charles would be it because it's
not doing anything.
Like no one's getting sick.
There's no lake rise in illnesses.
There's no like mind control going on.
There's nothing,
there's things happening or is no mind
control going on.
There is no mind control going on.
There is no mind control.
I mean,
it's the dumbest fucking thing.
It be easier to just put it in your
municipal water supply.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
as arguments that are doing that too.
Well,
of course,
of course.
They move it with a planes to the
appliances are spraying.
It drops,
it falls in the water supply and then
you drink it.
Something like that.
Anyway.
Yeah.
Spreading themselves too,
by the way.
But they're immune to it because they're
lizards.
You know,
they're down here too.
So you spray the sky indiscriminately.
I mean,
I guarantee you some Illuminati is,
or getting sprayed.
I'm going to get some hate mail for
this.
I know it well.
Yeah,
for sure.
We're getting it right now.
People were wiping the cheetos off their
greasy little fat fucking fingers right
now and hammering at the keyboards ready
to call a shills.
It's the dumbest.
It's what?
Um,
there,
there's a,
a guy who runs,
um,
what is the website?
Metal.
Bunk metal,
bunk.com what is his name,
Mick.
Anyway,
he,
uh,
he calls it the training wheels for
conspiracy theorist because it's above
your head and you seeing it all the
time.
You're like,
what is going on up there?
Why is l a very cloud like,
what is that?
And he started thinking,
man,
the government's doing something
secretly.
Yes.
Mapquest.
Thank you.
Oh,
metal bunk debunked.
Look,
midwest is a shill.
He's a shill.
Debunk,
debunk,
debunk.
He got death threats and hate mail when
he came on that TV show with me.
Woo.
Yeah,
no,
this is the guy.
Yeah.
This is,
how does this hedge fund manager makes
so much money?
Look at them.
Just look at him sweating.
Oh,
we'll get is.
Look at this annual returns of 13% 24%
or even 91% since 2013 how it's done
either it's just a computer program.
They have to pay for a decade up front
and if you leave,
he gets half the principal.
Oh Gee.
I wonder how it works.
Jesus fucking Christ you crook clients.
Hold on a second.
Co leaves it.
Clients aren't sure how it's done.
And Joseph A.
Meyer Junior,
the man behind the obscure Hedge Fund,
Al Our June lp is keeping his cards
close.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Invest most of his client's money in
safe treasury bonds.
Yeah,
it's safe as fuck.
If you can't take your money out for 10
years,
you know,
everybody in there can't take their
money out for 10 years.
That's insanity.
That's insane that that's that kind of
like,
I mean,
you don't know this guy,
but look at that.
What's that?
What does that all right?
I don't
know.
I mean if you had a gas,
uh,
if I had to,
I had to guess.
I'm going to give you two options.
Yeah.
Legit or scam.
Yes.
Um,
I don't know.
I would say it is most likely a Ponzi
scheme,
which is outrageous.
Something people throw around a lot.
But here's the interesting thing is why
do these schemes happen?
Right?
What do you look as though it,
his offer,
he offers an extraordinary guarantee
with our June.
You never lose my walk first as well.
What kind of names?
I think that's actually part of the
definition of an investment.
Fraud is guaranteed returns.
So if you make a guarantee like that,
um,
it's usually one of the triggers that
gets people investigated.
W he doesn't,
but you never lose money.
Yeah.
He's a great investment.
That's fantastic.
Investors should get involved.
Yeah.
Maybe put some bitcoin in that and to
solidify it.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to do the opposite.
If you invest your money in Bitcoin,
you will lose money.
Whoa.
He will.
He will gain money.
You will lose money.
You will gain money.
He will lose.
We don't know.
That's the no one is an,
and I want to be really careful about
this because many people go out and they
push the east things as investments and
you can have a lot of volatility and
sometimes when you have a lot of
policies,
some people get lucky and they make a
lot of money and some people are great
at picking their moment and they make
some money
bailout.
They make a ton of money.
Like right now we're at 600 bucks.
If you bought it back when it was like,
what was it,
the lowest point?
Uh,
the lowest lowest points,
no slowest,
uh,
about a thousandths of a dollar,
thousands of a dollar to two to 600.
You said it's,
yeah,
you could,
yeah.
So I mean if you put in like a fucking
big pile of money,
yes.
Five grand and dip,
he took it out the wrong moment,
you would lose all of it.
And this is why this isn't,
this isn't,
um,
a speculative instruments.
People can speculate in it.
All right,
isn't it,
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but isn't the well kind of poisoned the
financial well,
with speculative investing,
like what,
what people are doing?
It seems like it shouldn't be legal.
And what's really fucked up about it is
that they're doing it with algorithms
and they're their gambling and they're
there.
They're buying and selling within the
like a fraction of a second and they're
doing it.
The point where there was a radio lab,
um,
podcasts where they talked about how
investment firms,
did you see that one or listen to them?
Why?
I have heard that one.
Yeah,
we're investment firms moved their
servers closer to the exchange so that
he'd get in there their orders and their
exchange is quicker.
There is small on New Jersey.
Where are the data centers of the,
none of the stock trading happens in
Manhattan.
It happens across the water in New
Jersey as a data center,
there were probably largest amount of
money moves ever and they have measured
runs of fiber,
meaning that in order to be fair,
the fiber optic cable between the
service that do the trading and every
one of the rocks that are in the room
are measured to be the equal length so
that the speed of light limitation
across a room of a hundred feet does not
advantage one customer over another.
Is that incredible?
We're talking microseconds,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
if people have been forced because of
this,
to move their offices from the middle of
the country where they were two right
there or rent space where their servers
are right there.
It's really,
it's so bizarre because a lot of this
stuff is actually done with computers,
so these computers are operating on an
algorithm.
The algorithms recognize patterns.
They start these exchanges and they buy
and sell and buy and sell and buy and
sell and do all of this within fractions
of a second.
Yeah.
Over the last decade,
most trading floors have seen 90% of
their traders disappear.
So there are empty rooms.
You can see photos,
all that's online where it shows before
and after photos of very big banks like
ubs and jp Morgan,
Goldman Sachs,
companies like that.
Then you see their trading floor and it
is empty because a lot of that has now
moved to algorithmic trading.
So strange.
What a weird,
weird way to invest in bias.
Oh thank you.
Look at that.
Oh my God.
That's the before and after and it's not
because they're making less money,
right?
This is not a downturn.
This during this time they've actually
made more money.
But there's something about those stock
exchange videos that were in movies,
you know by,
by Sal,
Sal,
and they've got their hands up and
there.
I want two of these and five of these
and they're holding up pieces of paper
that is so daunting.
All that stuff is so confusing to a
person on the outside looking at that
and trying to figure out what the fuck
those people are doing.
Like it seems exciting and chaotic and
vibrant but so confusing.
Right.
But that is,
that is the American economy right now.
Essentially.
It's based on confidence all that's
happening.
Yeah.
So should we talk about a slightly
different topic?
Sure.
Whatever you want.
I want to tell you about some of the new
developments that are happening in
Bitcoin,
which I find interesting and I'm not
going to show,
cause this is not really about a company
or a specific product,
but I want to talk about one of the
things that has me excited,
which is a,
um,
what happens when you combine a
technology that looks very much like
pure to pure napster or bittorrent with
a merchant service like he bay and you
create this hybrid technology,
which is a completely peer to peer,
um,
store service called open bazaar.
And,
and this is basically a system where you
run on your computer,
some software,
and you can open a store to delivery the
physical goods or virtual goods,
have them listed,
have them found by others,
and then all of the payments are done in
bitcoin.
So by decentralizing the payment system,
we can also decentralize the the store
system completely.
And it is a completely borderless
multinational,
uh,
open and peer to peer opensource
software merchant system running on top
of Bitcoin,
which I just find fascinating.
The ability for anyone to open a store,
especially in countries where you don't
have Ebay,
right.
And be able to sell goods and services
anywhere in the world and receive
payments in Bitcoin and does this
operational right now?
Yup.
And I'm selling that book,
uh,
on Openbazaar.
So how does one access openbazaar to
the,
to the Luddite?
They,
they run software,
no fees,
no restriction.
And they downloads the software,
run it on their computer,
funded the bitcoin wallets and which
sits on their computer.
They don't have to give their money.
21,
there's no intermediaries and you buy
directly from the store and the person
running the store is running the same
software.
Well,
let's see what some of the things that
they have available.
We went to openbazaar.org.
I have to download the programs and I
find another way to look at it.
Oh yeah.
If you go to do duo search is a search
engine on top a d u o s e a r.
Dot.
C.
H.
So duo search.
Yes.
So because this is an open protocol and
because all of the listings are in a
peer to peer network,
you can just go online.
I run a search engine and create a
search engine that searches the store.
Wow.
This is a third party that just has a s
a search engine for searching the store.
So you can um,
you can search online there and uh,
tell her what you're looking for and
find something from tee shirts to gary
gets,
you can find my bank.
Okay.
But that's not what I wanted to show.
Look,
you can buy a flip phone,
go back there.
You can get a phone for Ari.
What's going on there?
A lot of these darks are going to flip
phones now.
20 Bucks for a Cryo Sarah,
or that's an LG LG 44.
It's kind.
Damn bargain.
Have you ever thought about going flip
phone?
Me?
Yeah.
No,
I'm in the opposite category.
I haven't actually received a phone call
on my phone probably in three years.
And really it's not,
I don't have a phone I had out of here.
I have a portable computer,
which also has a phone function on it
that I keep switched off.
You keep it off pretty much.
Yeah.
It doesn't bring ever.
It doesn't rain boot on my ring attached
to.
But people text you?
Um,
yes,
but that actually gets redirected to my
email.
So I don't do texts.
I,
I do it through either hangouts or
email.
So when I send you a text,
it doesn't really go to you as a text.
No,
it comes through to Google hangouts.
You are one of the weirdest guys have
room.
I know.
I use it as a portable computer.
It's my communicator device.
The phone function is irrelevant to me.
Well,
don't you ever want to talk to people?
Don't you go,
hey man,
how you doing?
Um,
I do video talks most of the time I know
I'm weird.
Okay.
Uh,
when I talk to people,
it's on,
well,
they're selling cbd oil,
CBD oil,
organic,
pure,
raw,
natural CBDC.
That is where the damn government's
gonna come in and close this whole thing
down.
What do you guys doing?
Mitigating pain?
You pieces of shit.
We're going to come in with dogs and
bite you.
Yeah.
They're probably actually only selling
that's within Oregon within a
jurisdiction where it's legal,
right?
Because they can sell it within that
jurisdiction from that jurisdiction.
And it's perfectly legal to sell
Colorado to clarify.
It's growing and getting in.
It's funny,
we're talking about how weird you are.
He showed up.
Uh,
Andrea has,
has a apple laptop and I was like,
how dare you walk in here with an apple
product?
I expect you to have some Linux box.
And of course he's running linux on his
apple computer.
Well,
I'm,
I'm also running Linux.
I'm running a bunch of things,
but yeah,
it's a beautiful piece of hardware.
I like it.
That doesn't mean that like everything
else the company does or you just don't
like the restrictive aspects of it,
right?
Yeah.
You're all android,
right?
Yes,
I am on,
what are you using now?
Which I have a nexus five.
Oh,
that's so,
okay,
so this is the newest and the latest
greatest of the Google phones.
So it runs the,
the pure google or did you,
yeah,
it's a,
it's no carrier branding.
It's,
I bought,
I own the phone.
It's not a lease.
Well,
those,
the newest,
latest and greatest android phones or at
the very least commensurate with the
newest and latest and greatest iphones.
I think the,
it's the average person that slight
differences in,
in hardware,
uh,
really are irrelevant at this point.
It's wall to wall.
Does matter.
However,
his watch you can and can't do with the
software and how much of your life at
controls and how much privacy you have
with the software that you run on these
devices.
As you may have noticed,
I'm all about control and privacy.
Being able to control my money,
control my devices,
control my privacy.
Um,
and I think that's,
that should be a principle that we
should all celebrate.
It's a fundamental freedom and we're
gradually losing it.
Well,
I'm a big fan of options as well,
so I'm happy that a android's come along
and created options.
Right.
Because it was for a long time it was
like,
yeah,
it's an option,
but it sucks.
Right.
And now it's not just,
I mean,
the Galaxy s seven,
have you ever messed with that Samsung
Galaxy s seven and I've seen it.
Yeah.
It's a phenomenal phone.
I mean it is easily as good as an
iphone.
It's an phone
and throw it into a gear vr headsets and
you get fully immersive vr.
That is mind blowing.
Yeah.
I actually have a little headset that I
can put this phone into and to Vr,
that stuff's good,
but it's not as good as the htc vive.
Um,
my friend Duncan Duncan trussell as the
vibe.
I also paid $30 for my headset.
Well,
I just,
you said the five is what,
1200?
It's probably something like that.
Yeah.
It's a slight difference in price.
Yes.
There's definitely a difference in
price.
Um,
but it is,
it's very encouraging that not only is
there a competitor to apple,
but it is actually an equal now,
you know,
and I just think the more options people
have like that,
the better there are for everybody.
And it would be nice if there was a
commensurate operating system because
there's not really,
well,
no,
not really.
Um,
for,
for Geek heads like me,
it's letting x.
But essentially what happened is because
Lennox was so successful,
it became android.
Android was built on top of Linux.
Essentially.
It is,
it at its very core,
it is Linux.
Right?
But why don't they make,
um,
that kind of an operating system for a
computer,
for a laptop?
Um,
because from what I can tell,
really,
laptops are gradually disappearing.
The laptop market is disappearing
really,
really fast.
Um,
today there were some announcements from
apple.
They're changing some of their operating
system commitments,
but they're making the m seven.
Yeah.
They're making the operating system more
and more like Ios,
um,
and gradually diminishing the importance
of,
of laptops because most people do pretty
much everything they need to do on their
smartphones nowadays.
It is,
it makes a difference that it's nice
that I can take my phone with me.
I have a,
the larger iphone that I use most of the
time,
and I also have a Samsung phone,
but they'll,
the larger iphone that I use,
most of the time I can take with me and
I don't feel like I'm missing a laptop,
but if I need to work on it,
get some stuff done,
I want a laptop.
Yeah.
I want to,
if I'm writing,
especially I want to be able to work.
Yeah.
You know,
I want to be able to also plug in
headsets and listen to music while I'm
working and also have power at the same
time.
And it says a lot of,
I'm not,
I'm a big fan of actual computers.
I like an actual computer at home with a
detached keyboard and a real monitor.
I mean,
I just think those things,
there's some benefits of those things to
someone who writes in particular.
Yeah.
Dog.
Do you think the great American novel is
being written by thumbs right now?
Well,
Steven Wright was writing a whole book
and tweets.
Yeah.
He was writing a novel in tweets that
got typed on a real keyboard for the
most part.
I ended up money where for people who
are listening.
Um,
so what else is exciting for you right
now about
bitcoin?
So I think one of the things we've seen
that that has been quite interesting is
that it has become easier and easier and
easier to use and easier to get into
bitcoin and easier to use bitcoin in
your everyday life.
I remember a time when it was very,
very difficult to do all of those
things.
Now there are probably six or 700
exchanges around the world.
Uh,
you talked about Mt.
Gox in Japan,
the first bitcoin exchange,
the really the first major bitcoin
exchange.
At the time it was the exchange.
There were no others,
and
that was both a single point of failure
and a weakness for bit coin as it
proved.
Um,
but it also made it very difficult.
Now there are at least four or five
major exchanges operating in the US,
very easy to access,
um,
access the system to connect it to maybe
to a bank account or a debit card.
And two,
if you want to convert dollars to
bitcoin or Bitcoin to dollars,
uh,
I'm mostly on the other side.
I earn bitcoin and then I converted into
dollars to pay for things that I can't
pay in bitcoin.
Very easy to do that.
That's a major advancement that makes it
much easier for people to get involved
as much as they want.
They don't have to earn everything they
don't have to do.
There's a company called bit wage,
which allows you to take a percentage of
your paycheck and have it sent to you in
Bitcoin.
Um,
and it's very easy for an employer to
set it up with any of the traditional
payroll systems where they say,
you can say,
just like,
I'm going to put 2% of my account into a
savings account in 98% into my checking
accounts.
A lot of companies offer that.
Well now you can say,
and I also want to put 2% of my paycheck
every month into this,
and to the employer,
it looks like a routing number and
account number,
but on the other end it gets converted
into bitcoin and send to your bitcoin
wallet.
So you can very easily incorporate this
as part of your everyday life.
Now here's another thing.
I'm going to try and show this in a way
that doesn't cause me a big problem with
my finances,
but how it had caused you a big problem
if someone sees something to show the
credit card number.
Oh,
I see.
So this is a,
this isn't Super Crypto
bitcoin credit card.
It's a bitcoin debit card and basically
it operates,
one of the exchanges in the u s offers
this and there's actually two or three
in the u s that now offer this kind of
service.
Now what's behind this is a bit coin
wallet.
So I don't have dollars in this.
I have bitcoin in this,
but when I went to the coffee shop or I
got this coffee earlier today,
I swiped this.
And um,
do they look at you sideways?
No,
I mean they can't tell.
They they see a visa card.
It says visa on the front says debit
visa.
It doesn't say bitcoin anywhere.
Um,
and so I make a payment and I get a
little message on my phone that says
we've debited 0.0002 bitcoin from your
account for your purchase at the coffee
shop.
So you could even tip them in bitcoin.
Yes.
Uh,
here's where it gets interesting.
You know,
I travel all around the world,
do these talks and these conferences.
So I'm constantly on the road and I've
tried again and again with my bank
account to tell them,
listen,
I travel.
When are you traveling,
sir?
All the time.
Where are you traveling next?
Oh 16 different countries in the next
seven months.
Can you just put a note somewhere on my
account that says do not block his visa
if it shows up somewhere we don't expect
because this person travels.
American Express can do it.
My Bank cat,
they simply can't.
They want me 24 hours before I leave to
call them and give them specific lists
of places that I'm going to be and when
I don't do that,
when I tried to use my card,
it gets blocked until I come back to the
u s and talk to them on the phone and
try a whole bunch of questions about
whether it was really me who bought,
you know,
a pastry in Prague or something like
that and then that all block it.
And what's happened to repeatedly in the
last few months is I'll go somewhere,
my card will get blocked because I
forgot to tell them and then I'll pull
out of the bitcoin card and it works
everywhere without fail because it's a
prepaid because it's a debit everywhere
without fail.
If I need to move more money into it,
if I need to take money,
cash out of an ATM when I'm traveling,
I can use this and it's so much easier.
I can simply transfer bitcoin into that
account and 10 minutes later I can
withdrawal.
That's in cash in any currency in any
country.
You say that with such glee,
it's convenience,
so excited about it.
You can't hide it.
Yeah,
I get it.
I get excited about these things because
it makes it easy for me to use Bitcoin,
right?
And yes,
it's visa,
the evil empire,
the banking system,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But for many people who are going to
experience bitcoin as an additional
currency in their life when they use for
online purchases,
having the flexibility to use both and
making it easier and more transparent is
how you get to mainstream adoption,
especially in the developed world.
Now,
how would someone get ahold of one of
those cards?
How do they just opened an account with
an exchange?
They have to do all of the Patriot Act,
Bank Secrecy Act,
show me ID,
proof of residence,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But in the end they get a visa card.
And what exchanges are available for
getting visa debit cards like that.
Like can you name some?
Sure.
Uh,
in the U s coinbase,
coinbase.com and Bitpay bitpay.com both
offer a visa debit cards in many
countries around the world.
Zappo x a p o offer a debit card and
there's a,
there's a bunch of others.
There's a bunch of others.
Interesting.
That's interesting.
That's actually very promising because
that makes it practical.
Yes.
So that's one side.
Then a few other things that have
happened in this space.
Certainly we have seen,
um,
a lot of the banking industry realized
that they could actually use this
technology,
uh,
and not just fear it.
And you know,
we have this and I certainly bring this
view of banks as giants,
Cara couture,
dinosaur evil things,
but within them,
there's just normal people,
right?
Swept up in the institutional inertia of
this beast.
But there's people who,
um,
some of them get it,
they get the,
this is exciting and interesting and
disruptive.
They want to use it within the banking
system and they're trying to work from
within to get people interested in this.
And we're seeing more and more of these
organizations gradually try to find ways
to adopt this technology to streamline
and to improve banking itself.
This is very similar to what we saw in
the early nineties when the Internet
started happening much more mainstream.
The phone companies at first fought it
tooth and nail,
right?
They fought the service providers tried
not to give them access to their lines,
try not to kick them off the DSL
networks at the time.
Um,
they fall to the FCC,
they tried to control it,
and eventually they all became ISB,
right?
So eventually jumped on the bandwagon
and use it to improve their own
infrastructure.
Now if you make a phone call on a
regular traditional old phone,
your phone call is going over the
Internet,
almost 90% sure that it is.
So they wouldn't let the Internet beyond
the phone network.
Now,
the entire phone network is on the
Internet.
If flipped,
that's called infrastructure in version.
Um,
in the early days of the automobile,
they wouldn't let automobiles in towns
too because they would disrupt the horse
traffic.
Right.
And they had all kinds of weird laws,
including in the UK.
They passed the law,
which required someone to run ahead of
the car with a red flag I call the Red
Flag Act.
That did wonders for the British
Automobile Industry,
which was 20 years ahead at the time and
then wasn't,
um,
wow.
That kind of reactionary behavior is
very common in new technologies.
And then infrastructure inversion
happens eventually.
The thing that was considered
impossible,
the roads would be paved to make
automobile travel practical everywhere
happened and horses were quite happy to
ride on paved roads.
Right.
Whereas for automobiles,
it was almost impossible to use in a
rutted muddy road when you have a four
wheel drive vehicle trying to compete
against a four [inaudible] drive
animals.
Yeah.
And in those early days they pointed
that said,
look,
this thing is never going to work.
Automobiles and never going to happen
because you don't have the
infrastructure.
But if you have the need infrastructure
happens,
and we've seen that with the automobile,
we that with electricity,
we've seen that with the Internet.
We've seen that with all of these
technologies and now we're going to see
it again with money because if you have
this technology,
building the banking institutions on top
of this is easy,
but making bitcoin or other
cryptocurrencies,
making the Internet of money play by the
rules of the old banking system is
almost impossible.
Now,
I like that expression,
crypto currency and crypto currencies.
What is the stop banks from creating
their own crypto currency and what mean
what is so wonderful about bitcoin in
comparison to other cryptocurrencies?
Now,
that's a great question.
There's nothing to stop them.
In fact,
they're already doing it are.
Yes.
First of all,
you've got to realize there's more than
a thousand cryptocurrencies already.
1,000.
Yes.
More than a thousand cups.
The worst one was the one.
We should avoid that.
That list is almost 900 long.
Oh
yeah.
I mean the,
it's a long tail.
Right?
Um,
there's a couple that are interesting
that offer different perspectives.
Um,
but we're,
we're seeing a lot of private
institutions interested in creating
their own.
Um,
and there's nothing stopping them from
doing that,
but they have to make a fundamental
choice.
They can either create some things that
is controlled,
contained with specific outlines and
borders,
with controlled access,
permissioned access,
as they would call it.
Um,
and that by definition is not global.
It can't be global.
It has to be contained within a specific
jurisdiction because that's how they're,
they operate.
Both corporations and banks operate
within specific jurisdictions,
so they can do that.
Um,
but then it has to be close to two
innovation,
close to permission and not global and
transnational.
And so what bitcoin has,
and not just bitcoin,
but any public open currency of a global
nature like Bitcoin,
is that you don't need to ask permission
to join.
You don't need to ask permission to
innovate.
create a new application and any
application,
you're right,
we'll instantaneously work anywhere in
the world to anyone without permission.
That's the magic of bitcoin.
And if you think about it,
that's also the magic of the Internet.
That's why the Internet has been
successful because it allows anyone to
join without permission,
connect to any application or service.
They won't write an application and
launch it globally without tasking the
phone company if they're allowed to do
that,
there's no one to ask permission from.
And to extend that analogy,
they also tried to build private
intranets and they're still trying
compuserve,
aol,
prodigy,
and the early closed networks that had
their own content that you could connect
to that weren't part of the Internet.
And then after that corporate intranets,
have you heard of the intranet term?
Right?
Yeah.
So when you have an internal network
within a company that has stale content,
crappy applications and doesn't talk to
the rest of the world,
and it's behind firewalls,
that's an intranet,
intra and trial.
And they've built those and they'd
sometimes serve very useful purposes,
but they're not the internet and you
can't scale them and make them secure
and make them useful enough.
So essentially that would be
exactly be what would happen with money
if local banks or national banks.
Yes.
So to follow from the title,
the,
the Internet of money is a very powerful
expression because it really explains
what this is.
This is the internet of money,
which means it's open,
borderless global and requires no
permission to participate.
And people will try to create the
intranet of money.
Um,
and it will have all of the limitations
that it's a traditional banking system
has.
Hmm.
So yes,
they can come along and do that um,
end.
The nice thing is that people don't have
to make a choice to use one or the
other.
The only system of monopoly we have is
that you have to use the national
currency of the country you were born in
and you live in,
in order to pay the government of that
country.
Other than that,
you're free to use any currency you want
anywhere.
Some of us are free,
many of us are not.
And bitcoin fits into that model.
It's the if you want to use it for this
particular use,
use it
well if,
if you extrapolate where all this stuff
was going,
if you,
you look at,
I mean if you're correct and if a over
the next 20 years bitcoin really does
emerge as not just an acceptable
currency worldwide but it's right up
there with everything else and and maybe
even preferred by a lot of people that
are in the know or tech savvy or what
have you.
If that really does take place,
it's going to slowly but surely erode a
lot of the major problems that we have
with society today as far as this
government having massive amounts of
control over the economy and the banks
being the ones who sort of in force the
kind of laws that have allowed the
mortgage crisis's and allowed these
bubbles to occur and also to fund and
help fund the politicians that enable
them to keep these laws in place.
I mean all of that sort of is a lot of
that is because of power and a lot of
that power is going to go away if
something like cryptocurrencies emerge
as being the predominant way that we use
and exchange money.
That's the optimistic way to look at it.
Yeah.
The less optimistic way to look at it is
that over the next decade we are going
to gradually move into a cashless
digital money society.
We're kind of doing that now with work
apple.
We are doing that already and there are
some countries that are completely
cashless really where that are very
close to completely cashless.
Ironically one of the,
one of the countries that has a very
high degree of um,
digital money is Kenya because of
Empaysah,
which is the mobile money they have,
which has now taken over a significant
percentage of the GDP.
We're also seeing in Scandinavian
countries now cash is less than I think
is less than 8% of um,
of the productive use of money using
credit cards is what you're saying.
I credit debit mobile pay APP.
What is Kenyon's MPA?
What does that and pay has a text
message,
money,
text message money.
Yeah.
It's money you can send through sms.
It started off as basically people
exchanging minutes,
mobile minutes that were transferable by
SMS and they started using it as
currency and then eventually it became
officially a corresponding currency to
the Kenyan Pesa.
And now as the predominant currency
it's,
yeah,
and in most places from what I
understand,
uh,
I haven't been to Kenya but I've talked
to a lot of Kenyans who tell me,
yeah,
we all use that and only that we don't
use cash.
We don't use credit cards.
Wow.
It is kind of shocking.
But here's the problem.
The problem is we are going to a digital
current society where cash will be
gradually eradicated either through non
use or a lot of countries and a lot of
governments are trying to actively ban
it.
So they're putting limits on how much
you can use cash.
Say you know,
$1,000 and if it's more than a thousand
dollars using cash as illegal.
When we go to the society,
we have to really think about the
implications.
Do we want a society in which our
digital money is under a complete
surveillance and complete control where
if you go to the wrong protest or if you
support the wrong political campaign or
if you make a payment to the wrong
person or receive money from the wrong
person,
suddenly your money disappears.
It's no longer yours anymore.
It's frozen,
it's seized,
it's gone.
Um,
and someone has control of that.
Corporations,
banks,
governments.
And in most cases there is no difference
between corporation,
bank and governments.
Right?
Um,
and so that's one scenario.
And the other scenario is one in which
individuals control their money.
It is digital money,
but it's digital cash like bitcoin where
you can pay an individual from one
person to another just like I can with
cash today without any other party
getting involved.
What really strikes me as amazing is
that we've gotten used to this idea so
quickly,
which is that we no longer pay people,
we no longer pay people directly.
The last we use cash is the more we pay
people through a corporation.
Right?
So from tipping your Valet to tipping
your taxi driver to tipping wherever
tipping is pretty much the last
remaining part of our society where cash
is used to pay from one person who is
not an incorporated entity to another
person who is not an incorporated
entity.
Everything else you have to pay for a
corporation,
whether it's a bank,
right,
whether it's Venmo,
whether it's paypal,
where they're at,
any of those things.
And we've gradually gotten used to this
environment where we can't pay another
person unless there's a corporation
involved.
And that's astonishing to me.
And as cash disappears,
that then becomes a final fact that
every single payment in your life will
be from Utah Corporation.
And the corporation takes a piece of
that every single thing.
And not just that,
it doesn't just take a piece,
it also controls and surveils and
monitors your juice.
And if you violate the terms and
conditions,
you are destitute.
Wow.
So are,
so the issue is not what we have today.
First is the digital currency of the
future or bitcoin or whatever.
It's both futures are a digital currency
and in both futures,
cash will no longer exist.
That is inevitable.
We are going down that road and now we
have to choose.
Do we go to the digital cashless society
of corporate control over money with the
complete and total merging of corporates
and state's money
where instead of having separation of
state and money,
you have the merging of state and money
and corporation and money where your
money is branded money,
you have chase dollars,
you have Goldman Sachs dollars,
you have coca cola dollars,
right?
You have money that is controlled by a
corporation or do we go down the other
future?
What we have money that is basically an
internet protocol that is completely
global,
that any person can pay any person they
meet in the streets without any
corporations getting involved.
Just for me to you digital cash.
And that's really the,
it's a less optimistic view because I'm
fully aware of what the other future is
and it's already playing out and it is a
very,
in my opinion,
a very dangerous future.
This is so fascinating to me because
it's so speculative and I love when you
don't know what's going to happen and
someone presents a bunch of different
scenarios and you get the mind starts to
wonder and then you also sort of plan
for the future.
Like it becomes like something to,
it almost becomes something to look
forward to our bed on.
You know,
like,
oh I bet it's going to work like this or
I bet you because we really don't know.
Right.
I mean,
and what,
what is the resistance that bitcoin is
facing from financial institutions that
are in control right now?
Because there must be some form of,
of resistance.
And is there any fuckery involved?
Like is there any sabotaging of bitcoin
that has been suspected or proven?
I think I,
I don't really know if there's any
sabotaging going on.
So that's,
that's a,
that's a claim expected.
I'm not going to make any,
any claims,
just wink at me.
Tell him what to say.
Well,
what I'm going to talk about is the,
the progression of what happens when a
giant,
well-established financial,
istation that's been around for 50 years
or 100 years is faced with a disruptor
that they cannot tamp down,
that they cannot shut down,
sue by coopt eradicate band,
legislate against.
Right?
And,
and what happens then is what I call the
five stages of grief.
Um,
first we start with denial.
So,
and,
and we saw this play out exactly like
this with a banking industry.
The first reaction was denial.
Bitcoin can't possibly work.
It's not real money.
It doesn't really exist.
It has no value.
It will never survive.
Fast forward five hears you keep making
that argument becomes less and less
credible because it's not real money.
Yet.
The big metal bird that brought me to
Los Angeles today was paid,
was not money.
So
you can claim it's not money all day
long.
And I've been living on it for three
years,
which kind of undermines the argument,
right?
Um,
if I earn it and I spend it and people
give me rides and big metal birds,
it's money.
Um,
so that isn't working.
It's going to go away on its own.
It's going to die.
It's going to lose all its value.
Every time it dumps in value,
they cheer.
It's like finally bitcoin is dead.
They write another obituary.
We publish them on Bitcoin,
obituaries.com to make fun of them later
and now has 110 obituaries I think
published every time they say,
well,
die,
which is every two months.
Again,
denial only works for a while.
Then they go into anger.
It's the money of terrorists,
criminals,
paedophiles pornographers and the
unsavory elements of this world.
Pedophiles.
That's always the one they pull out.
Right?
Oh,
they love to use that one.
Yup.
Yeah.
If they find one by one pedophile,
he uses bitcoin.
Pedophile current.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
dirty trick.
It is a bit of a,
it is a bit,
a bit of a dirty term trick and they've
tried to do this again and again and
again.
Um,
they did it with the intranet,
the intranet.
When it first came out they,
you,
you heard this media narrative,
the,
it's,
it sells papers.
It sell,
it didn't sell clicks at the time cause
that we're doing,
it's about the Internet but it sells
papers,
which is the idea that the internet is a
haven of crux and fraudsters,
terrorists and pdf files and
pornographers.
Great.
Um,
yes,
criminal use,
advanced technology,
the most advanced technology they can
get their hands on because they're in a
very highly competitive high margin,
high risk business.
And of course they're going to tell you
they criminals wear shoes to run away
from bank heist criminals drive cars to
get away from bank robberies.
They use cell phones to coordinate with
each other.
They drink water.
So it is not to die of dehydration.
We're not going to ban all of those
things.
Right.
And so you have that anger.
Um,
and they tried that for a while.
Every time they try that you just turn
around and say,
Oh,
well,
you know,
actually the biggest money launderers of
drugs in the world are HSBC,
the Hong Kong,
Hong Kong,
Shanghai banking consortium.
Inconvenient fact.
This is in the world.
Yes,
they would call it the model in your
laundering $700 billion for the Sinaloa
cartel over a period of 10 years during
which 19,000 people died in Mexico as a
direct result of that.
And they got a fine and no one went to
jail.
So there are inconvenient facts like
that.
Every time they say bitcoin funds
terrorism,
you say,
ah,
I see them driving Toyota's in Humvees.
Um,
that doesn't,
that's a bit in Congress.
Like they're,
they're driving around in the vehicles.
We left behind and there they got a lot
of their funding from pallets of money
that we left behind and they're getting
paid for dollar in dollars for oil that
they're selling to our closest allies.
We shouldn't really mentioned Saudi
Arabia.
Um,
so these are the inconvenient truths,
right?
So you don't talk about these in polite
company or at least you do.
Like,
that's what I said when I was invited to
speak in front of the Senate and Canada
and they started asking me about
terrorism and I said that actually
mostly funded by our allies.
And what did these say that was the end
of that train of thought.
They stopped too.
No,
no.
It was live public TV.
Like what went down when we moved on to
talk about more realistic and
interesting things in a much more
positive view of what this thing is.
They tried to discredit bitcoin by
attaching it to terrorism and you
informed them of the facts of where
terrorists are actually funded from.
Yes.
In a very public forum on live TV,
which was very difficult to continue
that line of conversation.
So that's anger.
Is there resistance in Canada isn't the
United States?
No,
actually they've been very,
very positive.
Very positive too towards um,
towards cryptocurrencies in general.
Yeah.
Interesting.
And there's a lot of development going
on.
There isn't that much resistance in the
United States really.
The banks were shutting down bank
accounts in some cases.
We've seen that in the United Kingdom to
what is the,
right right now,
like what's the percentage of people
that are using bitcoin on a regular
basis?
It's very difficult to say.
Um,
primarily because there is no clear
association between one person and one
bitcoin address or account.
There is no account,
right to use bitcoin.
All you have to do is download the
application on your phone.
Nobody,
you don't have to register anything and
so as a result it's just like how many
Ip addresses are in use.
Does that tell you anything about how
many people are using the internet?
You can't really tell.
That's a good thing.
It's,
it's because of its nature.
I would say we're probably looking at
about two to 4 million users based on
this.
Very interesting.
Based on activity levels,
based on logins to websites that some of
them publish results.
It's very hard to say for sure.
Exactly.
How many mostly concentrated in the u s
of the moment.
So it's a plus 1% somewhere in the range
of 1% of of the United States
population.
Oh No,
this is globally.
Oh,
globally.
Globally,
Maybe two to 4 million people.
And you said most of them are in the
United States?
Most of the main,
the United States,
many of them are also in China.
About a 4 million.
It is possible.
That's 1% of America,
maybe.
Yes,
yes.
Maybe half a percent.
Yeah.
Something like that.
That's interesting.
That's a lot.
But what is happening is it's doubling
every here in terms of transaction
volume,
transaction amounts,
number of everything is doubling every
year.
And that's,
that's the kind of characteristic curve
you see in disruptive technologies being
adopted.
And that's a very promising curve.
What is the tipping point?
Like what needs to happen?
Is there anything that needs to happen
for,
for widespread adoption?
You've got a need.
It,
uh,
it's got to be ready and it's gotta be
easy to use.
And so right now,
um,
it's not easy to use.
It's not ready for mass adoption.
And in many parts of the developed
world,
we don't really need it.
So in order to make it something we
need,
either what we already have has to not
work so well.
This is what's happening in the
developing world where you have banking
crisis,
which drives people into a safe haven,
or you invent to applications that
couldn't be done before.
A self driving car that you pay by the
mile automatically as you're driving
along.
Um,
uh,
um,
micro payments industry for paying for
contents directly.
Um,
the intranet of things where devices can
buy services online automatically.
Things that you can't do with credit
cards.
I think if you start seeing applications
like that to merge and I'm very
confident they're coming because we're
seeing the innovation behind them,
then you can make it something that is
more needed even in the developed world.
So what,
what do you think could be done to sort
of further this along or to accelerate
this?
Is there anything that can be done?
Um,
as I said,
I think the third ingredient is making
it easier for people to use.
And that's a matter of innovation and
maturity and we're doing that.
I mean,
that's already happening.
Other than that,
it's just a matter of time.
We just have to wait and be patient
until it happens.
What could be like the steps that can be
taken to make something like bitcoin
easier to use?
Well,
there's a lot of things to do.
Um,
user interfaces,
design security,
making backup,
EEC,
providing infrastructure services,
exchanges,
uh,
um,
your paycheck,
uh,
your atm services,
your debit card services,
merchant services,
things like that.
Um,
you know,
one of the examples I like to use is I
got on the intranet in 1989 I sent my
first emails shortly thereafter about
1,990 and in order to send my first
email,
I had to have a unix command line
skills,
a login into a unix mainframe with
access to an Internet connection at an
academic institution.
And then I worked very hard for about
two days to get the software working and
then eventually essence an email.
And then it took a couple of days to
cross the Internet,
right.
And then almost exactly 20 years later,
my mom went swipe and did the same thing
on her ipad.
So when you take,
you know,
two days of compiling software writing
complex unix commands,
sending an email and it takes a while to
get across the Internet and then 20
years later that's down to swipe.
When we can take fic coin from after
install a wallet to understand what it
is,
the Qr Code of the bitcoin address and
how do I back it up and secure it,
et cetera.
And you turn that into swipe,
then we'll be ready.
But there isn't there a vast difference
though between something like email,
which is not just a disruptive
technology,
but a completely new innovation.
The ability to send things wirelessly
through the air or even wired like
electronic mail did not exist but,
but males,
but mail did.
I mean it was just a change in the
medium.
Essentially you're doing correspondence,
but it's so much easier and more
convenient.
Whereas like using a credit card right
now is fairly convenient.
Yes.
Online banking,
fairly convenient for people who have
credit cards.
And now that's,
that's where the numbers really benefit
bitcoin because we're,
we're in the age of the Internet and
instead of economic inclusion becoming
crater instead of more people around the
world having ready access to these
technologies,
we're seeing entire country's getting
cut off from economic inclusion.
The banking system is not expanding as
fast,
uh,
to reach these populations.
And there's this vast gap left and this
gap is several billion people.
And into that gap you can fit anyone who
has access to even a rudimentary,
a feature phone or smartphone with a
very basic level of data service.
Um,
so the level at which you need to have
technology in order to,
for someone to adopt bitcoin and
immediately become in themselves a
global bank in the back pocket of their
pants compared to the level that you
would need to reach before jp Morgan
Chase built a branch within their area
and offer them services after going
through a very careful verification of
their identity and blah,
blah,
blah.
That's never going to happen.
So we're going to get to leap frogging
effect.
Just like in many places in Africa.
The first leap frogging events we saw
that was noted upon people wrote books
about this is the fact that in many
places in Africa,
landlines were never deployed because
the,
the difficulty to actually extend
landlines was so high that when cell
phones came along,
at some point it became easier to just
go directly to cell phones and bypass
that entire generation of technology.
Right.
So we're expecting,
and I certainly see it as very possible
to see leapfrogging in economic
inclusion,
the ability for people to join the
Internet of money long before they ever
see a bank.
The end result is it's not just about
banking,
the unbanked,
it's about debunking all of us to my
banking as an application.
You don't need an institution,
you just need an application.
And that that transition is pretty
powerful.
Is there any concern that people would
take people's phones and hold them at
gunpoint and just steal all their
bitcoin?
Like,
if that's all you own,
like if you have a wallet and that
wallet is all you own,
if you're on bitcoin 20 years from now
or whatever it is,
and that's it.
Your entire financial portfolio exists
on your phone and someone can come along
and force you at gunpoint to transfer
that over their phone and then they take
off in the night.
Yeah.
Uh,
well,
first of all already today,
you wouldn't keep your entire financial
portfolio on your phone.
I certainly don't.
Um,
there are a number of very convenient
and easy to use devices that allow you
to storage or bit coin securely on an
offline device.
Um,
I have a couple of my bag,
I might show them to you later,
which,
which allow,
you might,
but you might not.
I mean,
if you want,
I'll show them to you now.
Okay.
Let's see.
The way you said it was,
it's like teasing me.
This is it for people at home that are
listening to this,
you like,
um,
I don't know what to make of this.
I don't,
I didn't want to get wrapped up in the
headphone cord.
And,
uh,
what is that?
So this is a device that a lot of people
in bitcoin are familiar with.
Can we see that?
Yeah.
So this is called a bitcoin tresor.
It looks like one of those things,
those old ladies
ladies press when they fall down.
Yes.
I have fallen
and I can't get up.
Yes,
it's a bit different.
Um,
so this is a USB device.
I can connect it to my computer.
Can I see it?
Yes,
please.
Who have all your money now?
So feel weird.
You don't have all my money.
You have got it.
So I have,
I have a backup of that device.
Um,
and this is where what I mentioned
before is this 1224 word backups that I
have,
which means that if I lose that device,
um,
I can recreate,
it's on my backup device,
which I'm carrying here already.
Second one,
I have a second one.
You have four of these and you can
transfer that 24 words seed to any
device you want and it will immediately
have access to all of your money and
render this.
No.
Yes.
Ah,
well,
I mean it won't render this one now
because it can coexist on all of them,
but that one has a pin number and a pass
phrase that you have to put in.
You would not be able to break into that
device.
I could,
yeah.
Maybe most people can't.
I'm good at that shit,
dude.
Yeah.
Excellent.
But is it possible that someone could
figure out a way to crack your 24 word
code?
No,
I mean,
no.
No.
You say that man,
don't say that online.
I say that Fuckin hackers man,
they take that shit as a challenge.
Well,
never say you can't hack me.
Here's the thing.
Bitcoin in itself is the world's largest
bug bounty and this is something that
most people haven't realized bounty.
A bug bounty is when a manufacturer of a
piece of software,
for example,
puts out the bunting bounty and says,
I'll give you $10,000 if you find a bug
in my software that someone could
exploit to break my software.
Pull does bug bounties.
Google does bug bounties.
A lot of companies do these bug
bounties.
It's very wise and it's great because
what they do is that way they,
they find these,
they have professional packers really
who go in and break the software and
it's legal.
They do it perfectly.
Yeah.
But another way to look at this is the
bitcoin has 10 to $12 billion of market
capitalization behind it.
And if you can find a way to break,
say my 24 words seed,
you have access to my money.
So my money is the bounty that's sitting
behind that bug and this means that
bitcoin is being tested and has it been
tested every single day of its seven
year existence with an ever increasing
Jack Bolt at the end of it,
which is why you see bitcoin exchanges
when they don't do good security,
they get hacked and whoever hacks them
gets the bounty.
But bitcoin itself,
which has the biggest bounty of the mall
remains secure.
And the reason it remains secure,
Islam magical.
It's about spreading out the risk in
such a way that there is no single
point.
You can put your thumb on an attack.
So anyway,
this little device,
these types of devices,
there are ones that have a fingerprint
scanner on them that are easy to use.
They're um,
they come in various form factors.
We call these hardware wallets.
And what's interesting about this is
that the Bitcoin keys that's control my
bitcoin are created on this device.
They remain on this device and this
device signs transactions,
which means I can take it and I can plug
it into this laptop.
And if this laptop is compromised,
I don't care,
it will not be able to compromise this.
I can take this and I can plug it in to
the,
you know,
those desktops they have in hotel
lobbies where you can print your
boarding pass.
Okay.
Consider that the Cesspool of computing
you,
you go there.
That thing has 25 different viruses
fighting for dominance.
Right.
Once you plug in a device,
they start tearing each other apart,
trying to get to your device.
I can plug this in there and make a
bitcoin transaction and not have to
worry about that because the keys stay
on here.
Right.
And no one can figure out a virus for
one of those.
Well that's the thing.
This is designed specifically to have a
very,
very narrow well defined interface.
So the only thing you can send to it is
a bitcoin transaction and then displays
that bitcoin transaction on the screen.
And I can decide is that too I actually
wanted to pay.
Yes.
Confirm and then I've paid them and
nobody else.
Is it impossible to integrate a virus
into a bitcoin transaction
code messages and certain software like
it wasn't that what al Qaeda was doing,
what they were sending pictures and
inside the actual digital image,
the ones and Zeros,
there were encoding actual information
that you could read and you can embed
data,
the differences.
You can't execute that data because this
thing will not execute the data it
receives in the transaction.
It simply runs a fingerprint function on
it and signs it.
So yes,
the,
the point of this is that Jamie's
incredulous look at them.
Yeah.
Seems like it's,
you're setting a rule that's just going
to be broken in a month.
Like,
I can't do it today,
but next week we figured it out and now
we're,
well,
I,
you know,
I've had this device now for three
years.
Um,
this is one of the first additions.
I keep,
uh,
my bitcoin on there and I haven't had a
problem yet.
I don't put my money on exchanges.
I keep it on devices like this,
which is why I haven't had lou money
stolen.
The point of this is not to make it more
secure,
although it does,
it's to make security easy for someone
who's not technical.
I could create a whole elaborate system
as security experts to secure my
bitcoins.
That was never a problem.
The point of this devices that you can
secure your bitcoin,
my mum can secure her bitcoin without
really knowing how,
but just simply following how this
works.
So it takes security packages,
attendant device and simplifies it
dramatically.
Um,
that kind of thing.
Here's the other question you asked me.
What happens if someone points a gun at
you?
Right?
We call that the $5 wrench solution.
It's like,
shall we build a 10,000 super?
It's,
it's from a cartoon by Randall Monroe
and XKCD.
He says,
should we build a 10,000 supercomputer
to crack his encryption?
Um,
no.
Here's a $5 wrench.
Just beat him until he tells you what
the password is.
So resistance to that is difficult.
But one of the things that these devices
have and all the systems in bitcoin have
is duress passwords.
So you can put a small amount of bitcoin
in a specific accounts that opens with a
different password.
And so you shouldn't know.
So the people know,
they see the motherfucker,
you gave me the duress password.
Yeah,
but they don't know which one is which.
And this is a well known technique and
we actually recommend using fat as part
of it.
Listen,
when I go to a country,
uh,
where security isn't as good,
right?
I carry my cash in a money belt or leave
it back at the hotel in a safe.
But I also carry a bundle of notes,
high value notes,
like the equivalent of say,
$50 here in the United States in my
front pocket.
And if somebody comes at me,
pulls out a knife and says,
give me your money,
I will hand them my phone is a throwaway
cash.
I haven't in my front pocket.
And I will walk away from that,
listen to this podcast,
and they're going to know this
motherfucker has a belt and that's where
our real lewd is.
There you go.
That's it.
So I mean this is something a lot of
people do,
right?
Yeah.
I'm sure.
And that's why robbers are aware of it.
Yeah.
But for the most part they'll take the
cash that you hand them and run away
probably.
Yeah.
I can't help thinking like although
these little devices that you're storing
your bitcoin on look elegant in 2016 I
can't help thinking that they're just
going to be like those Gordon Gekko
giant brick phones when he was walking
around the beach looking like a pimp
from Wall Street.
Remember that movie that they are that
know like he's holding that big ass
[inaudible] they are that people will be
watching this show.
Yeah.
A decade from now.
Laughing at those,
laughing at those things.
And that's fine because guess what?
I just found a photo yesterday.
I was looking through some of my files.
I just found a photo of mate.
Yes,
thank you.
Look at him like a pimp with that big
stupid phone.
I found a photo of me from 1991 with a
leather,
uh,
side carrier with one of those in that
holster.
Right.
One of those brick phones is,
I think the second generation Motorola.
So it was about this big dot.
Can like ruin your hip,
like all that weight.
Look at that.
Yeah,
I was,
uh,
I was a sophomore in college.
It's like 1991 first cell phones who
just come out.
I'm in computer science.
I'm a geek.
I love gadgets.
So I go by one of the first cell phones.
It cost me an arm and a leg.
I paid like $5 a minute to make calls on
it.
$2,000.
Right?
I think I paid something like 750 pounds
sterling at the time.
It was probably about a thousand bucks
for a thing like this.
Who's battery lasted an hour.
Uh,
the batteries are so terrible.
I've got a fantastic photo of me with
the leather holster with that strategy
and I look so cool.
Can I see it?
No,
I don't have her with me.
We have a physical photo somewhere.
I actually found the physical foot.
I haven't digitized them yet.
When you do,
please send it my way.
I will.
Absolutely.
It was straight up on instagram.
I also have poofy hair in the front and
I'm wearing a ridiculous shirt.
You were Pimpin 1991 19 nature.
College.
Yeah,
I understand.
So yeah,
it will look ridiculous.
But the point that you make so well is
that we did go from Gordon Gecko to
them.
It says five,
right?
And,
and we're going to do that again in the
bitcoin technology.
This isn't something that's standing
still.
The amount of innovation that's
happening today,
even though it's not mainstream yet,
is staggering.
I work in this space full time.
All I do is read about what is new in
bitcoin and that's a full time job.
How many people are there like you?
Are you the only one like this?
No,
no.
Absolutely not.
The only one who's this integrated.
No,
absolutely not.
There are a bunch of people like you.
Yeah.
There,
there's probably about a thousand people
like you who are doing this.
Yeah.
Who were living off bitcoin constantly
investigating bid corn,
reading about it all the time,
lecturing and writing books about
bitcoin.
Well,
not so many lecturing and writing books
about it or speaking with conferences,
but there's hunt a hundred to 200 who
are doing that too.
Yes.
Hundred to 200.
Yeah.
Maybe you should talk to the other
hundred and 99 maybe they make better
guests.
You're crying.
You
know,
I,
there's,
I'm not claiming any special mantle
here.
There's lots of people who are very much
into it as I am and it is a full time
job and because so much is happening.
So yes,
you're right.
These devices will seem antiquated.
What this shows,
however is that won't,
when I came on the show the first time,
I think about three years ago,
um,
I didn't yet have one of these and I
used to store my bitcoin on what was
called a paper wallet,
which is basically where I print out to
additional keys with a convoluted
process to make sure my computer that's
doing the printing isn't compromised
cause then they're compromised and then
send the money to those digital keys and
then put those in a vault in a safe
deposit box in a,
in a safe.
And that worked great for two years.
I kept a small amount of bitcoin safe
that way.
Problem is,
it took a lot of expertise to execute on
that and there are many ways to get it
wrong.
So we've progressed now the way you back
this up,
as you write down 24 English words,
like how hard is that that it shows to
you one at a time on the screen and it
tells you,
write them down a runs with software in
a website which has really three or four
buttons.
It's fairly easy to use.
The device itself has two buttons.
I could probably teach my mom how to use
this and she owns bitcoin,
so that would be useful.
But,
and she owns one of these,
but it's still not ready.
She'd probably only use it when you're
around.
Yeah,
no,
she doesn't use it coming over.
Get Out.
My little goofy fucking bitcoin thing.
Let me pretend I use this for,
she wouldn't humor me that way.
No,
no,
no.
So the bottom line is that five years
from now this is going to be even
simpler and we keep iterating and
maturing the technology.
It's not standing still.
And as it gets easier and easier and
more people come on board,
not only are they able to use bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies,
but they're able to do it with security
in a way that doesn't require an
enormous amount of expertise.
And this is the same.
This happened with the Internet.
I remember this fantastic show you see
in 1994 and they've got good morning
America and there's this clip from the
outtakes they're doing before they're
doing this big internet story.
And they have the host chatting amongst
themselves before they started story and
one of them saying,
so what is the intranet?
Is that the email?
No,
no,
no.
That's just email.
So the at sign is the intranet?
No,
no,
no.
The outside his email.
It's the www.
That's,
that's Internet and Dotcom.
That's intranet.
And it's going through this process
where they're trying to grasp this alien
and strange seeming technology and all
of the terminology is weird.
Let's play this
as host.
Doing that little tease.
Definitely mark with the a and then the
ring around it.
So that's what I said.
Katie said she thought it was about,
yeah.
Oh,
but I'd never heard of it around.
I'd never heard of mark,
but never heard it said.
And then it sounded stupid.
What I said at violence add NBC
in the lunchroom.
You say if there is violence at NBC,
Ge Calm.
I mean alison should know what is
Internet anyway?
Internet.
Is that NASA computer network,
the one that's becoming really big now?
What do you mean?
That's how does want it know?
What do you write to it?
Like male?
No.
A lot of people use it and communicate.
I guess they can communicate with NBC
writers and producers.
Alison,
can you explain what Internet is?
No,
she can't say anything in 10 seconds or
less.
Alison will be in the studio shortly.
What does,
what does that mean?
A giant computer network made up,
made up of uh,
started from how I touch your hand.
Tell us what this was and then look in
the dictionary.
It's not an,
it's,
it's a computer billboard,
but it's,
it's,
it's several universities and everything
all joined together and others can
access it and it's getting bigger and
bigger roles.
Just spreading really handy during the
quake.
A lot of people,
that's how they were communicating out
to tell family and loved ones.
They were okay because all the phone
lines were down.
I was telling Katie and I call me,
you don't need that.
You don't need a phone line to offer
even know.
So if you show this,
that's awesome.
If you show this to a millennial right
now,
they're like,
ah,
94.
That was just before the civil war,
right?
This is 18.
Is it 1894 slavery was legal,
right?
They had TV.
Then back then it's like they can't even
conceive of a time when the Internet was
just so completely impossible to
understand.
I feel very fortunate that I grew up
without it and got to experience it in
my twenties right?
I experienced it emerge and I was like,
Whoa,
what is this?
But it didn't really have the same sort
of impact on my life that it has on the
lives of young people today that are
growing up with it right there.
I mean,
you look at kids today,
you go to a store or go to the mall or
something like that and to go to a
restaurant,
they're fucking glued to their phone.
They're glued.
All right.
Yeah.
Here comes the prediction.
This generation,
which is growing up right now,
they'd never know a world without
Internet.
They also never know a world without
bitcoin.
I don't dare you now,
15 to 18 years from now,
none of them are going to get the
driver's license because there will be
no self driving cars.
I need one and wouldn't be no driving
cars.
The fucking Montana where I could drive
my own God damn car won't be on hobby.
A hobby.
It will be a hobby.
And you'll pay $3,000 a month in
insurance to drive your own car.
How much?
I think you'll see.
That's where it's going to go.
Come on.
I don't know humans behind the wheel,
grandpa.
That sounds insane.
Housing dollars a month didn't.
So you're going to be telling your
grandchildren.
Yeah,
we used to drive our own cars and say
that sounds crazy.
Did to hundreds of thousands of people
die every year.
Yeah.
But we live like men.
Yes,
we didn't live suck in this digital
dick.
Like all these other policies out there.
Yeah,
there you go.
But think about it this way.
Imagine a child born today that never
sees cash.
You know?
I mean,
they travel to another country where
they're backwards and they still use
paper as money.
Right now it's entirely possible.
So what seems inconceivable to us then
becomes the norm.
Then it becomes inconceivable to live
without it.
Right?
And then you're trying to explain,
you know,
so what consensus algorithm did the
Federal Reserve use?
Oh,
it's used the 12 white dudes decide for
you consensus.
Was this,
what is a
proof of work algorithm?
No,
no johnny,
it was a proof of war algorithm backed
by oil.
I am happy you exist.
I love having you on the show.
I love talking to,
I love the fact that you have this
beautiful vision of digital currency and
if it worked and if you're correct and
it all pans out,
I think it's going to be amazing.
I love that you know so much about it.
I love that you come on here and educate
us.
I love that every time you come on there
really does seem to be more and more
progress.
It is tangible.
It's trackable.
It's interesting and it's fascinating.
And uh,
I'm all in,
I'm on team bitcoin.
I'm 100% committed.
I really wanted to happen.
Uh,
but it's just one of those things,
man.
It's just entirely fascinating.
And until it absolutely is here.
Like credit cards,
like the car,
like all the other things that you were
describing that really didn't exist
before and now exists almost primarily.
I mean,
I think,
um,
it's,
it's absolutely amazing and fascinating
and again,
in a lot of ways it's a solution for the
control that the federal government,
the Federal Reserve,
the banks and even politicians have over
us today.
That conduct control is slowly being
eroded by the Internet.
Not even slowly,
pretty rapidly being eroded by the
Internet.
Even whatever control politicians used
to have,
it's not nearly as,
it's not nearly as easy to hide.
It's so much more transparent.
It's so much easier to protest today.
It's just a different realm or living in
a different world.
And that world is happening incredibly
rapidly from a,
I got on in 1994 you were on before then
when it was like this really fragile,
strange internet.
I mean,
you were in the early days.
I'm really fascinated to see what it's
going to be like 20 years from now and I
really do hope you're right.
Well,
that's one of the beautiful things about
this is I think if you've experienced
things like this before,
and we're very lucky to be part of a
generation where we have,
um,
advancements in technology happening at
a rate where you don't just see one or
two,
but you see several in a lifetime,
right?
That are pretty earth shattering in
their complexity and involvement.
We've seen the Internet's,
we've seen social media,
we've seen the miniaturization of
computers.
Now we're going to see self driving cars
and digital currencies and all of these
other things in a single lifetime.
Once you've seen two or three of these,
you start capturing the pattern and the
pattern is when it starts,
everybody ignores it,
makes fun of it.
Can't possibly see how change would
happen,
right?
Um,
and this happened with the automobile
that's happened with electricity.
It happens with credit cards.
First time credit
cards were introduced.
Nobody thought they were going to work
is a crazy,
stupid experiment.
Nobody wanted to take them.
This happens with every type of
technology.
It's ridiculed at first and then
gradually it matures.
It gets less cumbersome to use.
And if it has some,
some fundamental properties,
some utilities,
something it's useful for that's
different,
that's new,
that you can do things with it you
couldn't do before,
then at some point it hits an inflection
point and it becomes mainstream very,
very rapidly.
And then everybody is both surprised and
at the same time claims ownership and
say,
well,
I always thought that this bit coin
thing would succeed.
Well,
let's hope we're those people.
Um,
this book is available right now.
The Internet of money.
Where can people get it other than some
funky exchange in some dark web corner
of the world?
Where can people get this?
Yeah.
So this is available on an obscure side
called Amazon dot.
Ca.
That fucking one.
Yes,
it's,
it's also available.
Uh,
it's going to book booksellers,
worldwide's and Amazon worldwide.
It's available on kindle,
kindle unlimited kindle lending library.
If you buy the print,
you get the kindle version for free.
It's available for sale for bitcoin.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
it's out now.
Actually.
It doesn't have any pictures in it.
What's up with it?
It does not have any pictures in it.
Um,
I have,
uh,
a giveaway for five copies of the kindle
edition and five copies of the print
edition.
Um,
people don't have to purchase anything.
They sign up,
they follow me on twitter and they have
a one in 100 chance of winning a free
book.
Um,
so if they want to try that,
uh,
Jamie here has the links.
Maybe they can go in the show notes and
people can try and get that giveaway or
something you could say over the air
that can be on that.
I'll put in the info on Youtube Info on
Youtube.
Okay.
All right,
folks.
Uh,
thank you very much,
Andreas.
It's always a pleasure to talk to you.
I hope you're right.
I really do.
And the Internet of money is available
right now.
Yes.
Right now I have copied number one.
You fucks right here in my greasy hands.
Thank you,
sir.
Always a pleasure.
Thanks for having me.
Okay.